THE ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE -- HIS CALL TO ORDER.
WE'RE GOING TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM SO MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER HERE FONG HERE FONG HERE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY HERE BERMAN
[inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW HERE CHAIR [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
DAILY NEAR DAILY HERE DEEP.
DEEP HERE FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GIPSON HERE GRAYSON [inaudible]
MEDINA.
IN A HERE IN THIS AREA.
THE SYRIAN PRESIDENT O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL PRESENT.
WE HAVE A QUORUM -- WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO ANNOUNCEMENTS --
MEASURES ON CONSENT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB.
ONE THIRTY SEVEN FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SB.
ONE NINETY SEVEN FILE ITEM SEVEN
SP.
TWO SIXTEEN FILE ITEM EIGHT SB
TWO SIXTY SEVEN FILE ITEM NINE
SB.
THREE SIX SEVEN FILE ITEM TWELVE
THREE NINETY SIX SEVEN THAT'S SB.
THREE NINETY SEVEN FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN SB.
THREE SIXTY SEVEN AND FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN SB -- THREE NINETY
SEVEN SIR MOTION WE HEARD A
LITTLE WOMEN.
SEVERAL MOTIONS IN SECONDS AND
SO WHAT.
WE HAVE I THINK IT WAS -- MISTER
GIBSON WAS THE FIRST MISTER
BIGELOW SECOND.
ADAM SECRETARY -- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THE CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG HI FONG I
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN
[inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE TI<c.cyan> [inaudible]</c>
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
YEAH.
DAVE I FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON.
I GIPSON GRAYSON [inaudible]
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN.
THIS AREA I O'DONNELL.
I THINK YOU PASSED ME UP.
I'M A YES.
MAYBE I WAS TALKING TO MEDINA I
DIDN'T HEAR MY NAME DALY AYE MR
MEDINA EXCUSE ME.
CAN'T WIN AROUND HERE.
THAT IS TEN WILL -- LEAVE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS IS IN
GERMAN -- SENATE IS IN STILL
SESSION SO WE WILL -- KIND OF
HANG OUT FOR A FEW MINUTES NOW
WE CAN START GETTING AUTHORS --
THEIR SHARED ME THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO BE.
HERE AS SOON AS POSSIBLE SO.
WE'LL TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF A
BREAK.
YOUR HONOR ROLL [inaudible]
LAKE HERE [inaudible]
HIGH QUALITY.
I CALL THEM
[inaudible]
WHICH PORTANTINO.
SB SEVEN PLEASE PROCEED.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
FOR YOUR ATTENDANCE [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU I MISS CHAIR MEMBERS.
ALL THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS --
TODAY I'M PRESENTING SB.
SEVEN WHICH PROHIBITS CALTRANS
FROM CONSTRUCTING A FREEWAY
TUNNEL SERVERS FREEWAY.
OR EXPRESSWAY FOR THE SEVEN TEN
BETWEEN THE I TEN HEN TO TEN
RESPECTFULLY -- IN NOVEMBER OF
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN CALTRANS
RELEASED THE FINAL E. I. R. E.
I. S. FOR THE SEVEN TEN NORTH
PROJECT.
THE FINALLY I ARE IDENTIFIES THE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM MANAGEMENT
TRANSPORTATION DEMAND MANAGEMENT
SOMETIMES CALLED THE T. S. M.
TDM.
AS THE PREFERRED ALTERNATIVE AND
EFFECTIVELY KILLS THE SEVEN TEN
PROJECT -- BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN WHEN I SAT DOWN WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION -- THE IDEA WAS
TO ALLOW CALTRAIN TO GO THROUGH
THE PROCESS.
CERTIFY THE I. R. -- METRO --
PICKED THE PREFERRED ALTERNATIVE
OTHER THAN THE TUNNEL AND AT
THAT TIME IT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE. TO DO A BILL -- AND
THAT WAS THE PLAN AGREED TO BACK
THEN AND I'M FOLLOWING THROUGH
ON THAT -- PLAN SB SEVEN ALSO --
IMPORTANTLY REQUIRE SURPLUS
NONRESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES IN THE
SEVEN TEN TO BE OFFERED TO THE
NON PROFITS -- AND THE CITIES AT
THE CURRENT USE VALUE INSTEAD OF
THE FAIR MARKET VALUE THAT'S
VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE THERE'S A
NUMBER OF VERY SIGNIFICANT
NONPROFITS INCLUDING MY
NONPROFIT OF THE YEAR --
ARLINGTON GARDEN WHO'S HERE
WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM THEM IN A
LITTLE WHILE IN A TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN CALTRANS BEGAN SELLING
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES AND PLANS
TO BEGIN SELLING.
THE NONRESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES
NEXT YEAR.
THESE NON RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES
ARE HOME TO SIX NON PROFITS SB
SEVEN WILL HELP THESE NONPROFITS
PURCHASE THEIR PROPERTIES --
THEY ARE RENTING -- AT AN
AFFORDABLE PRICE. FOR EXAMPLE
SCHOOLS WILL BE ABLE TO PURCHASE
THEIR SCHOOLS BASED ON THE VALUE
OF A SCHOOL PROPERTY.
NOT THEIR RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY
THE GARDEN WILL BE ABLE TO
PURCHASE ITS PROPERTY BASED ON
THE VALUE OF A BOTANICAL GARDEN
NOT BASED ON SOME OTHER.
USE AND THAT'S VERY SIGNIFICANT
SO TELL CALTRANS FINISHES THE
DISPENSATION OF THE SEVEN TEN
PROPERTIES IT MUST CONTINUE TO
CHARGE RENTS WHICH IS ALSO
SIGNIFICANT.
BECAUSE BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE FROZE
THE RANKS OF THE TENANTS IN
THOSE HOMES WHO WERE IN THE
AFFORDABLE RENT PROGRAM -- THIS
BILL WILL REMOVE THAT SUNSET AND
AGAIN ALLOW THOSE TENETS MANY OF
WHOM HAVE BEEN IN THOSE
PROPERTIES FOR DECADES WHO ARE
VERY LOW INCOME TO HAVE THEIR
RENTS FROZEN AND HELPED OUT.
SO TODAY OBVIOUSLY I'M ASKING
YOU -- TO SUPPORT THIS BILL THAT
DOES THREE VERY IMPORTANT THINGS
IT'S ALSO IN PLACE IF AND WHEN
CALTRANS EVER DECIDES TO DEAL
WITH THE STUFF IS BUT I'M.
STARTING TO LOSE FAITH THAT THAT
WILL HAPPEN BY THE END OF THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION BUT I'M VERY
PLEASED TO BE HELPING THE
NONPROFITS AND ONCE AND FOR ALL --
DISPENSED WITH THE SEVEN TEN
MOVES WITH ME FOR A SECOND.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE MEGAN FROM
THE PASADENA RONALD MCDONALD
HOUSE WHICH IS ONE OF THOSE SIX
TENANTS AND MICHELLE WHO'S FROM
ARLINGTON GUARDS [inaudible]
SO YEARS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MEGAN
FOKKER AND ON THE CO CHAIR FOR
THE WRONG THE PASADENA ROAMING
DONALD HAS BOARD OF TRUSTEES.
THANK YOU FOR GIVING US A FEW
MOMENTS THIS AFTERNOON TO TALK
TO YOU ABOUT WHY SB SEVEN IS SO
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
THE PASADENA RONALD MCDONALD
HOUSE PROVIDES A HOME AWAY FROM
HOME FOR FAMILIES IT MUST TRAVEL
FAR TO GET NECESSARY MEDICAL
CARE FOR THEIR CHILD.
BY THE HOME ENVIRONMENT TO KEEP
FAMILIES TOGETHER WITH THEIR
CHILDREN AT A TIME WHEN CHILDREN
NEED THEIR FAMILIES THE MOST.
BECAUSE WE OFFER OUR SERVICES
FOR FREE OR TO SMALL SLIDING FEE
SCALE -- PARENTS CAN STAY BY THE
CHILD'S BEDSIDE WITHOUT HAVING
TO WORRY ABOUT WHERE THEY'RE
GONNA TAKE A SHOWER WHERE
THEY'RE GOING TO EAT WHERE THEY
CAN SLEEP FOR THE NIGHT.
I ALMOST ALWAYS FULL AND WE HAVE
A VERY LONG WAITING LIST. FOR
ALL RONALD MCDONALD HOUSES ARE
LOCATION IS MISSION CRITICAL WE
MUST BE LOCATED VERY CLOSE TO
OUR PRINCIPAL HALL PARTS
HOSPITAL PARTNERS.
IN PASADENA WE ARE LOCATED IN
CALTRANS OWN PROPERTIES DIRECTLY
ACROSS THE STREET FROM
HUNTINGTON HOSPITAL AND A SHORT
DISTANCE AWAY FROM TRYING AS
MEDICAL CENTER.
IN THAT CURRENT LOCATION FOR THE
LAST FIFTEEN YEARS WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO SERVE OVER TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
SB SEVEN WILL HELP KEEP THE
PURCHASE PRICE OF THESE
PROPERTIES WITHIN REACH WHICH
WILL ENABLE US TO RAISE THE
COMMUNITY FUNDS NECESSARY TO
ACQUIRE THESE PROPERTIES WHEN
CALTRANS SELLS THEM.
THEY ARE GOING TO SELL THESE
PROPERTIES AND IF WE CAN'T RAISE
THE PURCHASE PRICE FOR THEM
THERE WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
RELOCATE.
MOST POSSIBLY OUTSIDE OF
PASADENA.
SB SEVEN WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
WE CAN STAY IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
CONTINUE TO HELP THE CHILDREN
ONE OF THE MOST VULNERABLE WHEN
THERE'S FIGHTING A VERY SERIOUS
ILLNESS RECOVERING FROM A
SERIOUS INJURY.
AND THAT'S WHY TODAY WE'RE
ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB
SEVEN THANK YOU.
NEXT WITH DECISION A MOVIE
REPRESENT PLEASE.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MICHELLE MATTHEWS AND THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ARLINGTON
GARDEN PASADENA.
IT QUICKLY LIKE TO TELL YOU A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT MY JOURNEY I
WAS BORN IN IRAN AND AND THE
DAUGHTER OF THE CHINESE AND
VIETNAMESE MOTHER AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN FATHER FROM NORTH
CAROLINA.
I GREW UP GOING BACK AND FORTH
BETWEEN HAWTHORNE HOME OF THE
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY AND SPACEX.
AND MY LA U. S. T. HIGH SCHOOL
IN SANTA MONICA WHERE I LEARNED
THAT THE QUALITY OF THE
LANDSCAPE AND TAX QUALITY OF A
LOT OF LIFE AND THAT URBAN TREES
ARE CRITICAL TO HEALTHY CITIES.
AND MY GARDEN FOUNDERS BUDDY IN
CHARLES WHILE WORKING WITH THE
LANDSCAPING COMPANY INVOICE
SCOUT TROOP.
WHO INSTALL THE WATER SAVING
DRIVE ARROYO IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT WE LOST BETTY TO HER
STRUGGLE WITH CANCER LAST YEAR
AND I WAS HONORED TO BE CHOSEN?
AS BY HER AS A STEWARD OF OUR
GARDEN EXACTLY TWO YEARS AGO TO
THIS DAY. ONE OF THE REASONS
ARLINGTON IS SO SPECIAL IS THAT
IT FEELS GOOD TO BE THERE OUR
MISSION IS WE ARE A COMMUNITY
BUILT CLIMATE APPROPRIATE
HABITAT GARDEN.
OFFERING LEARNING INSPIRATION
ENJOYMENT FOR ALL.
OUR GARDEN WAS GROWN ON AN EMPTY
LOT THAT SAT VACANT FOR ALMOST
FORTY YEARS IT WAS PURCHASED BY
CALTRANS IN ORDERS STORE HEAVY
EQUIPMENT DURING THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE SEVEN TEN
CAN YOU IMAGINE THAT CALTRANS
HAD BUILT A BEAUTIFUL GARDEN
INSTEAD OF A FREEWAY.
WELL THEY DON'T THEY NOW THEY
DON'T HAVE TO BECAUSE WE DID.
TODAY ARE TWO AND A HALF ACRE
MEDI TRAINING GARDENS ONLY
FOURTEEN YEARS OLD.
BUT BECAUSE OF DEVOTED COMMUNITY
LEADERS WE HAVE OVER FOUR
HUNDRED TREES AND THOUSANDS OF
VISITORS YEARLY OUR GARDEN
DEMONSTRATES PRINCIPLES OF WATER
CONSERVATION AND LAND REFORM.
IT HAS BEEN SUPPORTED BY
INDIVIDUAL TO MAKE DONATIONS
MARMALADE SALES IN THE CITY OF
PASSAGE.
PASADENA AND IS ON A SHOESTRING
BUDGET.
THE CITY ALREADY KNOWN FOR ITS
TREES WE ARE VIBRANT OPEN SPACE
USED EVERY DAY BY CHILDREN
SCHOOL SENIOR CITIZENS PLANT
LOVERS AND WILDLIFE ENTHUSIASTS.
WE ARE CHERISHED BY OUR
COMMUNITY AND OUR THE HOME MADE
RESULT OF LOVE CONVICTION AND
DETERMINATION.
WE STOP THE FREEWAY AND INSTEAD
WE GREW A GARDEN.
PLEASE VOTE YES ON SB SEVEN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
SO DO WE HAVE ANY -- WITH THIS
IS A SUPPORT THE BILL I'M GONNA
ASK YOU FOR YOUR NAME THE
REPRESENTING IN THE ME TWO OR
SOMETHING VERY VERY SHORT.
HI I'M CATHERINE GARCIA WITH
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CURE RUSSELL
BEHALF THE CITY'S A PASADENA AND
SOUTH PASADENA BOTH IN SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS INJURY AND
WE ARE ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY WE
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU GIVE ME WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO HAVE CONCERNS WITH
OFFICE BUILDING THE AUDIENCE
WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS IT AT THIS
TIME.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
SIR WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR FOR
ALLOWING MY WITNESSES TO HAVE --
SIGNIFICANT TIME I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I BOTH.
THANK YOU SENATOR -- WE'LL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY SO
MADAM SECRETARY WE YOU CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER AYE FRAZIER AYE FONG
[inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
I BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
Q..
CHIU I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE DALY.
DALY AYE DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON R. GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
SEN I MEDINA.
MEDINA I IN THIS AREA.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I IT IS TEN LEAVE ROLE
PERHAPS A MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
COMMIT A FEW.
CENTER SKINNER.
SB [inaudible]
FORTY FOUR GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
SB. FORTY FOUR SEVEN OUT OF THE
TENT CITIES ACROSS THE U. S.
THAT HAVE THE LEAST HEALTHY IN
THE MOST POLLUTED AIR.
ARE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO WHILE WE CLEARLY ARE VERY
PROUD OF CALIFORNIA'S --
LEADERSHIP WITHIN CLIMATE
PROTECTION.
WE STILL HAVE A LOT WAYS TO GO.
JUST TO MAKE OUR AIR HEALTHY.
AND THAT ON HEALTH YEARS WE KNOW.
CREATES A LOT OF HEALTH PROBLEMS
SUCH AS ASTHMA AND OTHER THINGS
I WANT SITE ALL THOSE.
TRUCKS AND BUSES SO MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES THAT ARE
FUELED WITH TRADITIONAL DIESEL
ARE KEY BECAUSE OF THE POOR AIR
QUALITY.
AND THE PARTICULATE MATTER FROM
DIESEL EXHAUST. TO CLEARLY HELLO
MY PINE.
HAS SERIOUS HEALTH IMPACTS.
AS WE KNOW THIS FROM OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE NEAR THE
PORTS AND YOUR GOODS CORRIDORS
LIKE BY -- TEN NINETY ONE I
EIGHTY AND OTHERS SO WHAT IS SB
FORTY FOUR DO.
IT DIRECTS OUR AIR RESOURCES
BOARD TO UPDATE THEIR PLANS ON
HOW.
THEY'RE GOING TO HELP OUR MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES.
MEET THE FEDERAL CLEAN AIR
STANDARDS.
AND CALIFORNIA'S OWN GHG GOALS
THAT ARE ALREADY IN STATUTE.
AND IT HOW THEIR WHAT STEPS ARE
GOING TO TAKE BY TWENTY THIRTY
AND THEN BY.
TWENTY FIFTY IT ALSO ASKS THEM
TO IDENTIFY POLICIES THAT CAN
REWARD FLEETS THAT MOVED TO LESS
POLLUTING TECHNOLOGY.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE MY
WITNESSES.
YEAH.
THAT MEANS BE BRIEF OKAY
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON [inaudible]
KAREN MEMBERS.
SORRY QUALITIES GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I MERIT
ALEXANDER THE POLICY DIRECTOR
CAL START THANK YOU TO SENATOR
SKINNER FOR YOUR POLICY
LEADERSHIP ON THESE ISSUES.
I WILL BE BRIEF -- WE ARE A
TECHNOLOGY CONSORTIUM FOUNDED
OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO
WORKING WITH OVER TWO HUNDRED
MEMBERS TODAY TO ACCELERATE THE
GROWTH CLEAN TRANSPORTATION --
WE REPRESENT COMPANIES LIKE PER
TERRA MOTIVE BE Y. DE CHANGE
THAT OF ALL -- COME BACK TO
CALIPER COME TO CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE OF OUR CAP AND TRADE
FUNDED PROGRAMS FOR MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES.
SO WE ARE SEEING THE
COMMERCIALIZATION IN VARIOUS
PHASES OF VARIOUS OF DIFFERENT
TYPES OF MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES TODAY.
AND AS LONG AS THE STATE'S STAYS
THE COURSE WITH ITS CLIMATE
COMMITMENTS THESE TRENDS WILL
NOT ONLY CONTINUE WE EXPECT BUT
INCREASE -- WE JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT IT TAKES
MANUFACTURES BETWEEN FIVE AND
SEVEN YEARS TO BRING A NEW
PRODUCT TO MARKET.
AND THEY'RE UNLIKELY TO START
THIS PROCESS UNLESS THEY CAN
LOOK OUT AND SEE A CLEAR PICTURE
OF WHERE THE STATE IS HEADED.
SO IN CLOSING BUSINESSES ARE
MAKING INVESTMENT DECISIONS ON A
LONG TERM BASISAND THE STATE
NEEDS TO MORE CLOSELY SINK IT'S
PLANNING AND APPROPRIATIONS FOR
THESE PROGRAMS WITH THOSE
INVESTMENT CYCLES.
AND THEREFORE CONTINUE TO DROP
MORE MANUFACTURERS AND INVESTORS
TO THE STATE. FOR THESE REASONS
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M WILL BEAR
WITH THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA -- MRS
SENATOR NOTED CALIFORNIA'S HOME
TO SEVEN OF THE TEN MOST OZONE
POLLUTED CITIES IN THE UNITED
STATES SIX OF THE MOST PARTICLE
STATES.
A MAJOR SOURCE OF THIS POLLUTION
IS THE HEAVY DUTY MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY TRUCK SECTOR.
AND SO THAT'S WHY WE SEE THIS IS
SUCH AN IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH.
CLEANING UP THE SECTOR AND
MAKING SURE WE'RE MEETING ARE
CLEANER AND CLIMATE STANDARDS.
IN THE INTEREST OF PUBLIC HEALTH
REDUCE REDUCTIONS IN ASTHMA --
ASTHMA ATTACKS CARDIOVASCULAR
ILLNESS LUNG CANCERS AND OTHER
RESTORING CARDIAC DISEASES WE
ARE YOUR SUPPORT FOR US WE FORTY
FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT THE AUTHORS BILL PLEASE
TYPE THE MIKE STATE YOUR NAME
FOR YOU REPRESENT AND KEEP IT.
ROCKY RUSHING WITH COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CHECK A BUSTER REPRESENTING CAL
PERK AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
BENJAMIN PORTER WITH ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
ALAN ABBAS WITH THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TO CRIED WITH A NOT TO
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL HERE
IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
AT JULIE NINE ASK ABOUT HALF THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION SUPPORT.
JOSIAH YOUNG A MAP OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL GAS VEHICLES
COALITION SUPPORT.
CATHERINE GARCIA WITH SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
SYLVIA SOLELY SHOP WITH ADVANCED
ENERGY ECONOMY IN SUPPORT.
RYAN KENNEY CLEAN ENERGY IN
SUPPORT.
JIM WEINBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
TO CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THERESA WRECKAGE ON BEHALF OF
CERES IN SUPPORT.
TIM CARMICHAEL ANDHAVE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GAS COMPANY IN
SUPPORT.
BETSY THAGGARD FOSSEL FREE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
JUDY POPE THREE FIFTY BAY AREA
ACTION IN SUPPORT.
CORY BOWLES ON BEHALF OF BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS IN
SUPPORT.
AARON RODRIGUEZ FOR THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN SUPPORT.
JANET **** FOR THREE FIFTY
SILICON VALLEY IN SUPPORT.
EVAN MEN TEN WITH PLACES FOR
PROGRESS IN SUPPORT.
ON A MOUNTAIN SMITH WITH THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY CANCER
ACTUAL NETWORK ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MADISON BY ON BEHALF OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON IN SUPPORT.
I LET HIM KNOW THAT I'M
REPRESENTING B. Y. DE AND NEXT
IN CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
BERNIE GARCIA WITH C. ON OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL SERVICES AND THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING SAYS
HE SHOULD SUPPORT.
YES OVER THERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE STILL ARE IN SUPPORT AFTER
THE MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS BUT
I'M ENCOURAGE LEGISLATURE TO AND
CONSIDER. TO CONTINUE
CONSIDERING MULTI YEAR
INCENTIVES FOR THIS PROGRAM.
ADRIAN WE WITH THE WESTERN
PROPANE GAS ASSOCIATION'S SPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC STILL
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OR
SHARE CONCERNS WITH THE AUTHORS
BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MISTER MEDINA.
SHE WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD -- I
REPRESENT -- RIVERSIDE WHERE.
WE HAVE A LOT OF TRUCK TRAFFIC
AND WE'RE I WOULD NOT BE
SURPRISED IF THE CITY OF
RIVERSIDE MORENO VALLEY MIGHT BE
ON THAT LIST.
SO IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO US --
IT CLEAN -- CLEAN AIR AND CLEAN
TRUCK SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING THE BILL.
FOR THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MISTER
O'DONNELL.
OKAY I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR BRING THIS FORWARD AND
NOW THIS IS IMPORTANT TO ME AS
WELL I HAVE BOTH PORTS MY
DISTRICT.
AND THOSE TRUCKS THAT GO THROUGH
MY FRIEND AND FROM RIVERSIDE'S
DISTRICT.
PROBABLY AM EMANATE FROM THE
PORT OR HEADED TO TO THE PORT --
WE HAD A CHANCE TO CAP AND TRADE
TO MAKE A MAJOR INVESTMENT IN AN
EFFORT LIKE THIS WE DIDN'T GET
THERE THIS YEAR IT'S VERY
UNFORTUNATE.
SOMEONE OUT THERE BROUGHT UP
MULTI YEAR FUNDING THAT'S WHAT
WE NEED TO DO OVER GONNA GET TO
THE PROMISED LAND.
BUT AGAIN I I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU BROUGHT BEFORE US TODAY SO
THANK YOU.
HERE THE QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
CENTERS CAN REJECT CLOSE.
THANK YOU -- PRESHEAF YOUR
SUPPORT AND THAT'S MY CLOTHES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR SKINNER I'M OF
VERY THANKFUL YOU WORKING WITH
INDUSTRY TO FIND WAYS TO HELP
FUND.
TECHNOLOGICAL -- CHANGES WE NEED
THIS -- IN THESE SECTORS OF SO
THEY CAN REACH CIRCLES.
I'LL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY AND MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
FRAZIER AYE FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG NO AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN
[inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO CHILL.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY.
DALY AYE DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I THE BILL HAS NINE
LEAVE THE ROLE BEEN TRAPS
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU [inaudible]
CENTER LEYVA.
SB.
TWO TEN PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF MISTER CHAIR I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS BILL IN YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF I REMEMBER LAST YEAR WHEN
WE ENDED UP HOLDING THE BILL AND
WE SO WE WORK TOGETHER SO I
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MEMBERS SB TWO TEN ESTABLISHES A
SMOG CHECK REQUIREMENT FOR
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL WILL APPLY SIMILAR
RESPONSIBILITIES TO TRUCK
OPERATORS TO MAINTAIN THEIR
EMISSION CONTROLS AS WE ALREADY
REQUIRE OF THE CARS THAT WE
DRIVE DALY.
UNLIKE PERSONAL PASSENGER
VEHICLES CURRENT LAW DOES NOT
REQUIRE HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS TO
HAVE REGULAR SMOG CHECKS TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR EMISSION
CONTROL SYSTEMS ARE WORKING
PROPERLY THROUGHOUT THEIR
LIFESPAN.
APPROXIMATELY ONE MILLION HEAVY
DUTY TRUCKS TRAVEL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA ROADS ANNUALLY AND
ARE MAJOR CONTRIBUTORS TO THE
STATE'S POOR AIR QUALITY.
STATEWIDE NEARLY TWELVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS LIVING COMMUNITIES
THE FAILED TO MEET FEDERAL CLEAN
AIR STANDARDS HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS
OPERATING CALIFORNIA ACCOUNT FOR
NEARLY 60%.
OF HARMFUL OXIDES OF AN OXYGEN
KNOCKS.
AND 82% OF DIESEL PARTICULATE
MATTER PM TWO POINT FIVE A
POTENTIALLY CANCER CAUSING AIR
CONTAMINANT MEMBERS DIRTY AIR
COST CALIFORNIA OVER TWENTY
BILLION DOLLARS AND
HOSPITALIZATION VISITS TO THE
EMERGENCYROOM.
AND CHRONIC ILLNESSES EXPOSURE
TO THESE HARMFUL CONTAMINANTS IS
DIRECTLY ASSOCIATED WITH
INCREASED HOSPITALIZATIONS FOR
CHRONIC HEART AND LUNG DISEASES
AND OTHER SERIOUS HEALTH IMPACTS
FOR ELDERLY ADULTS.
AND YOUNG CHILDREN THE
CONSEQUENCES ARE MUCH WORSE IN
CERTAIN REGIONS ACROSS THE STATE
LIKE THE INLAND EMPIRE AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WHICH ARE GREATLY
AFFECTED BY LARGE TRUCK TRAFFIC.
AND CONGESTED FREEWAYS JUST LAST
WEEK WHEN I LANDED IN ONTARIO I
LOOK TO SEE WHAT THE WEATHER WAS
AND EVEN THOUGH IT LOOKS LIKE IT
WAS A CLEAR AND PRETTY DAY.
MY PHONE SAID THAT AND THE AIR
WAS ON HEALTHY FOR CERTAIN
ELEMENTS CERTAIN -- GROUPS.
DESPITE THE INVESTMENTS WE HAVE
MADE TO SUPPORT A TRANSITION TO
ZERO AND NEAR ZERO EMISSION
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES.
DIESEL TRUCKS WILL CONTINUE TO
OPERATE ON OUR ROADS FOR DECADES
TO COME WE'VE TAKEN THE BOLD
STEP OF MAKING SURE THAT THEY
MAINTAIN THEIR MISSION CONTROLS.
THROUGHOUT THEIR LIFESPAN WE
HAVE TO TAKE THAT STEP.
THIS SECTION ALONE WILL PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT AIR QUALITY AND
PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFITS.
OVER THE NEXT DAY DECADE SB TWO
TEN WILL ASSIST IN THE REMOVAL
OF SIXTEEN HUNDRED TONS OF
HARMFUL PARTICULAR MATTER WHICH
IS THE EQUIVALENT OF TAKING
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND TRUCKS.
OFF THE ROAD NOT ONLY WILL SB
TWO TEN HELP IMPROVE PUBLIC
HEALTH AN AIR QUALITY IT WILL
ALSO IMPROVE THE LIFE EXPECTANCY.
OF HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS AS BECOME
MORE FREQUENTLY MAINTAINED.
THIS BILL ALSO APPLIES TO OUT OF
STATE TRUCKS AND WILL HELP LEVEL
THE PLAYING FIELD FOR LAW
ABIDING CALIFORNIA TRUCK OWNERS
AND OPERATORS.
SIMPLY PUT SB TWO TEN WILL BE A
WIN WIN FOR CALIFORNIA
INDUSTRIES AND PUBLIC HEALTH
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS I'VE
WORKED DILIGENTLY WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. TO ROOF FOR A
BALANCED MEASURE THAT ADVANCES
CLEAN AIR AND INCORPORATES
INDUSTRY INPUT.
WITH THE MOST RECENT AMENDMENT
SEVERAL ORGANIZATIONS HAVE MOVED
TO NEUTRAL INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING ASSOCIATION
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE
AND CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU HAVE
BEEN ACTIVELY ENGAGED ON THIS
ISSUE OF SHARED IMPORTANCE.
AS THEY TO WANT TO STATE TO THE
STATE TO FAIRLY ENFORCE VEHICLE
STANDARDS AND EMISSION LAWS.
I REMAIN COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH INDUSTRY AND CLEAN AIR
ADVOCATES IN ORDER TO CREATE A
BALANCED AND SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM.
THIS INCLUDES WORKING TO ENSURE
THAT VEHICLES HAVE A REASONABLE
AND COST EFFECTIVE PATH TOWARDS
COMPLIANCE INCLUDING LOW USE AND
SPECIAL PLATED VEHICLES.
WE ARE IN AGREEMENT THAT A
COMPLIANCE MECHANISM SHOULD BE A
PLACE THAT WILL ENSURE THESE
VEHICLES CAN CONTINUE TO BE
OPERATED.
LAWFULLY AND WITHOUT PENALTY SB
TO SET TEN IS SUPPORTED BY
DOZENS OF ADMIRE BUYER MENTAL
HEALTH AND CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY
ORGANIZATIONS HERE WITH ME IN
SUPPORT TODAY IS MEREDITH
ALEXANDER POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
CAL START.
AND BILL MCGOVERN POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR.
KAREN MEMBERS AND THANK YOU TO
SENATOR LEYVA.
I'M.
I WON'T SAY AGAIN WHAT CAL START
AS IN WHAT WE DO BUT ARE TWO
HUNDRED MEMBERS INCLUDE
NONPROFITS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
LARGE FLEETS SUCH AS UPS FEDEX
AND FRITO LAY.
WE ALSO RUN A SUSTAINABLE FLEET
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM.
SO AS YOU KNOW MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES ARE THE BACKBONE
OF OUR FREIGHT SYSTEM WHICH IS A
MAJOR PART OF THE STATE'S
ECONOMY HOWEVER THEY ALSO EMIT A
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF
POLLUTANTS AND GHGS -- WE KNOW
THAT OUR MEMBERS PROPERLY
MAINTAIN THEIR HEAVY DUTY FLEET
TO ENSURE THEIR IN COMPLIANCE.
HOWEVER SOME FLEETS ARE GROSS
POLLUTERS AND THIS CREATES A
COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE FOR THE
FLEETS WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE AND
MAINTAIN THEIR EQUIPMENT
PROPERLY WELL THE BAD ACTORS ARE
ABLE.
TO CONTINUE POLLUTING OUR
COMMUNITIES AIR.
THE CURRENT LACK OF SMOG CHECKS
FOR TRUCKS ESSENTIALLY EQUATES
TO AN UNFAIR TAX ON RESPONSIBLE
BUSINESSES AND AN UNFAIR TAX ON
OUR CHILDREN'S LUNGS.
SB TWO TEN WILL LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD BY ENSURING THAT
EVERYONE IS HELD TO THE SAME
STANDARD WHEN IT COMES TO
VEHICLE EMISSIONS.
THIS BILL WOULD ACTUALLY HELP
MANY FLEETS BY STOPPING LOWER
AND OPERATORS THAT HAVE
POLLUTING VEHICLES FROM UNDER
UNDER CUTTING THEIR MORE
PROFESSIONAL OPERATIONS.
AND THIS BILL IS DONE IN A
SENSIBLE WAY IT'S MEANT TO BE A
LIGHT TOUCH REGULATORY SYSTEM
AND IT SETS OUT A STREAMLINED
PROCESS FOR FLEETS THAT HAVE AN
ESTABLISHED COMPLIANCE HISTORY.
SO WE KNOW THE CARD WOULD
DEVELOP THE PROGRAM THROUGH A
FULL REAL MAKING INCLUDING A
PUBLIC STAKEHOLDER PROCESS WHEN
OTHER ISSUES COULD BE -- WORKED
OUT IN DETAIL SO IN SUMMARY THE
BILL PROVIDES A WORKABLE
APPROACH TO TAMPING DOWN ON
GROSS POLLUTERS WHILE AVOIDING
UNNECESSARY RED TAPE.
AND NO FLEET OPERATORS SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO CIRCUMVENT VEHICLES
THE STATE'S VEHICLE EMISSION
STANDARDS SB TWO TEN WILL ENSURE
PARITY ACROSS ALL INDUSTRY
STAKEHOLDERS AND THEREFORE WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BILL AGAIN
WITH COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR
SUPPORT AND WE THANK CENTER
LEYVA FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I ALSO WANT TO THANK MR
THROWN IN WITH THE COMMITTEE FOR
HIS WORK ON THE BILL.
I'M QUITE CONFIDENT THAT
VIRTUALLY ALL OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS WOULD BE SHOCKED.
IF THEY KNEW THAT THERE IS NO
SMOG CHECK FOR TRUCKS ALREADY.
THERE IS NO COMPREHENSIVE
INSPECTION AND MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM FOR HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES.
THAT'S ANALOGOUS TO WHAT WE HAVE
WITH OUR CARS WE KNOW ONCE THEY
REACH A CERTAIN AGE WE HAVE TO
GO THROUGH A SMOG CHECK.
AND THE ADVANTAGE OF THAT OF
COURSE IS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
EMISSIONS THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY
GETTING ON THE ROAD.
ARE WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
WHEN THE ENGINE IS CERTIFIED.
IT'S ODD THAT WE HAVE THIS SMOG
CHECK FOR PASSENGER VEHICLES BUT
NOT FOR HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS GIVEN
THAT AS YOU'VE HEARD FROM CENTER
LEYVA AND FROM SENATOR SKINNER.
MOST OF THE MAJOR AIR POLLUTANTS
ACTUALLY ARE COMING FROM THE
MOVEMENT OF GOODS RATHER THAN
THE MOVEMENT OF PEOPLE.
AND IT'S ALREADY BEEN FOUND THAT
FOR SOME OF THESE TRUCKS THE
EMISSIONS ARE ACTUALLY UP TO
NINE TIMES ON THE ROAD.
WHAT THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO BE
WHEN THE ENGINE WAS CERTIFIED
AND THE WHOLE POINT OF AN
INSPECTION MAINTENANCE PROGRAM
IS TO CATCH THAT AND FIX IT AND
WE THINK IT WILL BE?
A SMALL MINORITY OF THE TRUCKS
THAT ARE ON THE ROAD THAT ARE
ACTUALLY GENERATING MOST OF THE
POLLUTION.
HAVING THIS MEASURE IS -- AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF CALIFORNIA'S
PLANTS REDUCE AIR POLLUTION IT'S
ALREADY IN THE STATE'S OFFICIAL
PLAN TO COME INTO ATTAINMENT.
WITH CLEAN AIR ACT HEALTH
STANDARDS.
AND IN FACT THAT PROCESS OF
PUTTING THIS IN PLACE IS ALREADY
UNDER WAY.
THROUGH THE EARLY STAGES OF A
REGULATORY PROCEEDING BUT WE
THINK PUTTING IN ITS A STATUTE
HAVING THE LEGISLATURE INVOLVED
IN CRAFTING IT WILL MAKE IT A
MORE EFFECTIVE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU.
MOVE THE BILL.
ANY MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THANK
STEP UP TO THE MIKE AND WE ZERO
SUPPORT THE BILL PLEASE TAKE
YOUR NAME THE REPRESENTING.
AND ME.
TOO JOSIAH YOUNG ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL GAS
VEHICLES COALITION IN SUPPORT
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THE LAST
AMENDMENTS.
ALSO A MAP OF THE BIO ENERGY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE.
THANK YOU.
WE KEEP A CROWDED WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL HERE IN SUPPORT.
THERESA BROKERAGE ON BEHALF OF
CERES AND SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO AT THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
SUPPORT AND I WAS ALSO ASKED TO
PASS ALONG THE SUPPORT OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND.
JAKE ABBAS REPRESENTING CALPERS
IN SUPPORT.
BENJAMIN PORTER REPRESENTING
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
JUST MULLIN FLEA AND PRIVATE
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
RYAN KENNEY BEHALF OF CLEAN
ENERGY AND SUPPORT.
BETSY THAGGARD FOSSEL FREE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
CATHERINE GARCIA ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
PREDATORS THE ON BEHALF OF
VALLEY CLEANER NOW IN SUPPORT.
CORD BLOOD SOME HALF OF BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS IN
SUPPORT.
AARON RODRIGUEZ WITH THE UNION
OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
LINDA CHRISTIAN WITH A
CALIFORNIA BICYCLE COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
WILL THERE IN AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
OUR MARTIN SMITH WITH THE
AMERICAN CANCER SLICE SOCIETY
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
YES MY FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE IN SUPPORT.
CLEAR BROWN FOR FOR THREE FIFTY
BAY AREA ACTION IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JUDY POPE SPEAKING FOR SAN DIEGO
THREE FIFTY IN SUPPORT.
JANET **** FOR THREE FIFTY
SILICON VALLEY IN SUPPORT.
JIM WEINBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
A CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. SEVEN
MEN TEN WITH VOICES FOR PROGRESS
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THE END OF OSCARS WITH
CALIFORNIA ROOM TO US IS ONLY AS
A STRONG SUPPORT AND THANK YOU
FOR THE AUTHORED FOR BRINGING
THIS.
PART THANK YOU.
I'LL HAVE ANOTHER BAND
REPRESENTING NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT.
ADAM HARPER CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTION DUST FROM MATERIALS
ASSOCIATION WE WANNA THANK THE
OFFICER FOR AMENDMENTS AND WE
SWITCHED TO NEUTRAL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT HAVE.
ANY SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
GOING ON TO ANY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC HAVE ANY OPPOSITION HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL PLEASE
TAKE [inaudible]
COMING UP.
WE NEED TO MAKE SOME ROOM FOR
THE OPPOSITION AUTHOR
[inaudible]
SO.
WE HAVE ONE MORE [inaudible]
GOTCHA.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR NAME YOU
REPRESENTING PLEASE IN
OPPOSITION.
AB MARIJUANA CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION HERE -- WE'VE
REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION ON THE
BILL WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR -- INNER STAFF FOR ALL
THE WORK THAT'S GONE INTO THIS
BILL -- OUR PREVIOUS LETTER
POINT OUT TO CONCERNS THAT WE
HAD RELATING TO THE VIçT
ALREADY.
AS WELL AS THE FIX FIX A PERIOD
FOR THE OUR CULTURAL VEHICLE --
BOTH THOSE HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED --
SPECIFICALLY ON THE P. LANGUAGE
THE LATEST SET OF AMENDMENTS I
ENSURE THAT THE AUTHORITY
REMAINS WITH THE LEGISLATURE --
AND NOT DELEGATE AND NOT RIGHT I
DELEGATED TO AIR BE SO -- AND IT
YEAH IN ADDITION TO THE FIFTH
ALREADY -- THE THREE REPORTS
THAT ARE MANDATED TO COME BACK
TO LEGISLATURE WE THINK YOU'RE
GONNA GO A LONG WAY TO ENSURE
THIS THIS -- PROGRAM IS
IMPLEMENTED CORRECTLY THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
NO WELL CREAMERS CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S WORK ON
THIS BILL -- MANY OF OUR
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED
HOWEVER WE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
CONCERN.
THAT REMAINS TO BE ADDRESSED AND
THAT'S AROUND THE ISSUE OF LOW
USED VEHICLES AND VEHICLES THAT
ARE LICENSED AS SPECIAL
EQUIPMENT VEHICLES.
SO IN THE LOW USE IN INSTANCE
THESE THERE ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED
TRUCKS IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT ARE COMPLYING WITH THE
DIESEL TRUCK AND BUS RULED BY
KEEPING THEIR MILEAGE UNDER A
THOUSAND MILES IN RURAL AREAS
THERE MAY NOT BE ANY.
LOCATIONS WHERE THIS TESTING
COULD OCCUR AND THAT WOULD
REQUIRE THEM TO PUT ON
SIGNIFICANT MILES TO COMPLY WITH
THE REQUIREMENTS UNDER SB.
TWO TEN AND SO WE NEED TO HAVE A
WAY THAT THOSE VEHICLES CAN
COMPLY WITHOUT ON THREATENING
THEIR COMPLAINTS OPTION UNDER
THE DIESEL TRUCK AND BUS.
I DO SEE THE SENATOR NODDING HER
HEAD.
IN THIS PLACE YES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JUST AN OLD FIELD ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION -- WITH
MY COLLEAGUE FROM FORMER WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHORS OFFICE FROM
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL
ADDRESSING -- AT LEAST ONE
CONCERN RIGHT NOW WHICH IS THE
FIX A TICKET THAT WAS MENTIONED --
INCREASING THE DAYS FROM FORTY
FIVE TO SEVENTY FIVE WE WOULD
GREATLY APPRECIATE THAT IN
ADDITION TO THE OUTSTANDING
ISSUE THAT MISS KRAMER'S
MENTIONED -- ALSO MAKING SURE
THAT ESSIE PLATED VEHICLES
LARGELY IMPLEMENTS OF HUSBANDRY
WHICH CAN BE ANYTHING FROM A
TRAILER TO A FEED TRACK OF
COURSE A TRAILER NOT REQUIRING
TESTING OF THIS PROGRAM BUT A
FEW TRUCKS CERTAINLY.
REQUIRING TESTING WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE VEHICLES CAN
COMPLY -- IF THERE'S NO MOBILE
SOURCE TESTING THAT IS PROVIDED --
WE KNOW THAT THE BILL ALLOWS FOR
IT BUT ALLOWING FOR IT AND
PROVIDING THAT SERVICE ARE TWO
VERY DIFFERENT THINGS -- WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THOSE VEHICLES
DON'T OF VIOLATE THEIR
REGISTRATION AND LICENSING
CONDITIONS WHICH TYPICALLY ARE
JUST DRIVING ONE MILE
INCIDENTALLY UP AND DOWN THE
ROAD BETWEEN FORMS.
CERTAINLY WOULD BE ABLE TO
COMPLY -- IF THOSE VEHICLES DID
NOT HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
MAKE IT TO A TESTING FACILITY SO
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
SERVICES ARE NOT ONLY AVAILABLE
BUT THEY'RE ECONOMICALLY
FEASIBLE -- TO ENSURE THAT AGAIN
HAVING SERVICES PROVIDED IN LA
COUNTY -- MAY MEET THAT THE TEST
FOR A OR B. TO OFFER THOSE
SERVICES BUT IF THE TRUCK IS
LOCATED MODOC COUNTY I DON'T SEE
HOW IT'S ECONOMICALLY VIABLE. TO
YOU -- TO TO GET THOSE MOBILE
TESTING FACILITIES UP THERE SO
WITH THAT LOOK FOR WORKING THE
AUTHORED APPRECIATE -- OF
AFFORDABLE THANK YOU.
THANKS.
I HAVE MY GROUPS HERE ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION -- PUBLIC
UTILITIES -- PUBLICLY OWNED
UTILITIES IN CALIFORNIA --
UNLIKE THE PRIVATE FLEETS THEIR
THEIR THEIR HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
ARE ACTUALLY REGULATED BY CARD
RIGHT NOW UNDER SOMETHING CALLED
THE THE FLEET REGULATION FOR
PUBLIC AGENCIES AND PUBLIC
UTILITIES AND AND AS WE KNOW WE
UNDERSTAND SB TWO TEN IS GOING
TO COME AT YOU.
YOU SURPLUS AT REGULATION AND
WHAT WE WHAT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE IS THAT THERE'S GOING
FORWARD THE PUBLICATION SHE'S
WERE ALREADY DOING THINGS -- ON
AVAILABLE CONTROL TECHNOLOGY
THINGS -- AND AND AND INSPECTING
THEIR VEHICLES ALREADY KIND OF
CONTINUE IN THE SAME MANNER THAT
THEY'RE THAT THEY'RE CURRENTLY
OPERATING UNDER SO SPECIFICALLY.
AN IN PAGE FOR THE ANALYSIS --
POINTS THIS OUT WE'RE WE'RE
LOOKING FOR THE ABILITY FOR
THESE PUBLIC AGENCIES TO
CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO DO IN THE
HOUSE -- TESTING OF THEIR
VEHICLES IN THEIR FLEETS -- ON
YOU KNOW ON THEIR SITES AS THEY
DO NOW UNDER THE UNDER THE LOCAL
AGENCY -- RULE THAT THEY'RE
COMPLYING WITH AND THAT THAT'S
PROBABLY OUR MAIN CONCERN
THERE'S A COUPLE OTHER THINGS
ABOUT STREAMLINING -- EXISTING
RATRI PROGRAMS WITH THE CHP AND
SOME LANGUAGE TO ENSURE THAT
THAT THE THAT THE IN THE AUTHOR
POINTED OUT THAT THE THE INTENT
TO HAVE OUT OF STATE -- VEHICLES
COME YOU KNOW SHOULD BE
CERTIFIED COMPLY WITH THE LAW WE
WANTED TO WE WE WOULD APPRECIATE
SOME CLARIFICATION AROUND THE
FACT THAT THE FEES FOR FOR FOR
ARISTIDE VEHICLES.
THAT THERE IS SOME LANGUAGE IN
THERE SAYING THAT THERE WILL BE
FEES FOR OUR OUT OF STATE
VEHICLES -- TO ENSURE THAT YOU
KNOW CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS AREN'T
SUBSIDIZING THE COMPLIANCE COSTS
FOR VEHICLES COMING IN FROM OUT
OF STATE SO WE WOULD APPRECIATE
SOME LANGUAGE AROUND THAT THANK
YOU FOR THAT.
NEXT WITNESS PLAYSTATION AMY
REPRESENTING.
HER FRAZIER NUMBERS SHAUNA GIRL
WE HAVE A WESTERN STATES
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THAT'S
MOVING UNDER CORRECT IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION THANK OU TO THE
AUTHOR.
THE BIG ISSUE FOR OUR MEMBERS
WHO ARE ALREADY REELING FROM
VERY SIGNIFICANT TRUCK AND BUS
REGULATION COSTA CARD.
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER COST ON TOP
OF A COST ON TOP OF COST IF YOU
RECALL.
TRUCK AND BUS REGULATION
REQUIRES MIGRATION TO TWENTY TEN
OR NEWER TECHNOLOGY WHICH IS
VERY LOW EMISSIONS LEVEL.
ADDING THIS COSTLY PROGRAM
ALTHOUGH COULD IS THE AUTHOR FOR
PUTTING THE COST PROCESS THROUGH
THE LEGISLATIVE.
PROCESS HOWEVER THE COMPLEXITY
PART OF REQUIRING AN OWNER
ANNUALLY TO DRIVE TO A FACILITY
SIMILAR -- TO JUSTIN'S COMMENTS
IT'S VERY NOT WORKABLE CURRENTLY
SO LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR TO MAKE IT MORE SMALL
TRUCKER FRIENDLY.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES THE BACKBONE IN
CONSTRUCTION TRUCKING AND OTHER
MEMBERS THAT -- WE REPRESENT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITH
THIS PLEASE TO TRIMMING YOUR
REPRESENT.
YET JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON THE
OTHER CALIFORNIA FUELS
INCONVENIENCE ALLIANCE WE
REPRESENT 95%.
OF THE FUEL MARKETERS AND CON
HERE'S THE WHOLE THE FUEL IN THE
STATE -- WOULD ECHO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE JUST MADE
YEAH WE DO BELIEVE WE DO BELIEVE
THE BILL IS MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND WE APPRECIATE ALL
THE AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN TAKEN
BUT WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME
ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT ON THE
COMPLEXITY ASPECT OF THE PROGRAM.
THANKS.
THANKS WITH THIS PLEASE YES --
REFERRING CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE REMAIN OPPOSED LESS
AMENDED FOR THE REASONS OUTLINED
BY MY COLLEAGUES AT THE FARM
BUREAU AND CATTLEMEN'S.
THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THEATER IN OPPOSITION TO THE
AUTHORS BILL ARE HAVE CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE -- QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE MR REASON.
THANK YOU CHAIR -- CENTER LIVE
AT THANK YOU O MUCH FOR YOUR
TREMENDOUS WORK ON THIS AND YOUR
WILLINGNESS -- TO GO BACK AND
FORTH NEGOTIATE AND COME UP WITH
THE BILL THAT YOU HAVE.
IT WAS MENTIONED ABOUT -- ESSIE --
PLATED VEHICLES A SPECIAL --
EQUIPMENT VEHICLES AND THE
STRUGGLE OF THE CHALLENGE IT IS
TO TAKE THEM TO INSPECTION SITES.
IT WAS ALSO MENTIONED THAT IN
THE BILL IT IS PROMISING THAT
ALLOWS FOR MOBILE INSPECTIONS IS
THAT IN YOUR YOUR INTENT TO KEEP
A PERMISSIVE OR IS IT YOUR
INTENT. TO PROVIDE A MOBILE
SERVICE FOR INSPECTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
ABSOLUTELY IT IS -- WE ACTUALLY
HAVE A LITTLE OUT LIST OF
DIFFERENT WAYS THAT THE VEHICLES
CAN BE INSPECTED -- THE MOBILE
INSPECTORS ARE DEFINITELY ON ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT ONES.
TELEMATICS DONGLES WHICH
TRANSFERRED THE TRANSFER THE
DATA VIA SL YOUR NETWORK OR
STATION BASED WHICH WOULD BE AT
THE STATE STATION BASED OR
KIOSKS WHERE YOU DRIVE A PLUGIN
AND TRANSMIT DATA.
SO WE HAVE A WHOLE MENU OF OF
THINGS THAT WE COULD DO I THINK
CANDIDLY A LOT OF THAT WILL
DEPEND ON WHAT THE FEE STRUCTURE
IN SEPT BEING.
AND HOW MUCH THEY CAN AFFORD TO
IMPLEMENT BUT I THINK THE MOST
IMPORTANT ONE IS ABSOLUTELY THE
MOBILE AND A AND A OR B. HAS
ALREADY SPOKEN TO US ABOUT THAT.
AND THEY ARE VERY INTERESTED IN
DOING A MOBILE TESTING SO WE
HAVE DO WE HAVE A COMMITMENT
FROM A OR B. THAT THE YES
IMPLEMENT.
WHAT THEY SAID AS THEY INTEND TO
DO MOBILE TESTING?
THANK YOU IN MY QUESTIONS ALONG
SIMILAR LINES AND I SALUTE THE
AUTHOR A VERY VERY IMPORTANT
PROGRAM IN ITS -- IT'S TIME --
TO PRESS FORWARD IN THIS AREA --
MY QUESTION IS REALLY MORE A
PROCEDURE WHEN THE FEE PACKAGE
COMES BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE.
WILL ISSUES LIKE MR GRAYSON JUST
ADDRESSED THE MOBILE -- OR KEY
OSCAR APPROACH WILL THAT BE
INCLUDED -- SO THAT IF THERE ARE
DETAILS LACKING WERE MISSING
FOURTH THERE'S THINGS WE DON'T
LIKE.
WILL HAVE -- ANOTHER BITE AT THE
APPLE.
SO WHAT OUR UNDERSTANDING IS IS
IT WILL COME BACK TO US THROUGH
THE BUDGET PROCESS AND IT WILL
PROBABLY BE IN A TRAILER BILL SO
WE WILL HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY. TO DISCUSS IT AND
ADD AND SUBTRACT LIKE WE DO WITH
OTHER TRAILER BILL.
IN HOW FAR OFF IN THE FUTURE DO
YOU BELIEVE THIS WILL BE WOULD
IT BE NEXT BUDGET PROCESS TWO
YEARS.
GOTCHA THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY
LAST QUESTION.
IT WAS A MENTION OF THREE
REPORTS THAT WILL COME BACK NO
WAS ONE OF THOSE THE FEE
STRUCTURE YES AND THEN WHAT ARE
THE OTHER TWO REPORTS THAT WILL
BE COMING BACK SOMEBODY
MENTIONED THREE MAYBE I
MISUNDERSTOOD -- THE THOSE ARE
ON THE PROGRAM ITSELF SO -- AIR
BE WOULD BE EXPLAINING WHAT WILL
BE IN THE PROGRAM SO YOU HAVE A
CHANCE TO REVIEW THAT OKAY.
SO THAT THE DETAILS THE
OPERATIONAL DETAILS OF THE
PROGRAM WILL BE.
IN A REPORT IN IS THERE A THIRD
OR DID I MISUNDERSTAND.
SO TWO COMPONENTS THE FEE
PROGRAM THE FEE STRUCTURE.
IN THE OPERATIONAL COMPONENTS SO
THERE IS ANOTHER REPORT AFTER --
AFTER POPE PROGRAMS IMPLEMENTED
TO DISCUSS HOW IT'S BEING
IMPLEMENTED AND TO GO INTO HOW
THE ENFORCEMENT'S GOING AND TO
JUST MAKE SURE THAT IT'S BEING
ENFORCED PROPERLY.
GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
MISLABELLED STRIPS.
AS A CURE.
FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
FOR BRINGING THIS -- MEASURE
BEFORE SOMETHING IS COMMON SENSE
I DON'T THINK AS THE BALL FOR
PRO SOMEONE'S COMMEND YOU ON
THAT -- I HAVE A TRUST FACTOR.
THEY ARE BEING IN TERMS OF
FOLLOWING THROUGH -- THE WHAT IS
BODY -- MAKES RECOMMENDATIONS TO
LEGISLATION.
AND SOME OF THOSE.
DON'T GET IMPLEMENTED.
AND SO -- REQUIRES A MANDATE
HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT THE WORD
MANDATE. TO MANDATE THIS WELL
FIRST I WOULD SAY I AGREE WITH
YOU THERE CAN BE SOME TRUST
ISSUES -- WE HAVE NOT YET
THOUGHT ABOUT A MANDATE MY HOPE
WOULD BE THAT IF WE LEGISLATE
THIS THEY WILL DO IT IF THEY DO
NOT THEN YES WE WOULD PROBABLY
HAVE TO LOOK AT A MANDATE.
IS IT A MECHANISM IN THE BILL
SOMEWHERE ME ABOUT OVERLOOKED IT
IN TERMS OF WHERE.
THIS WILL COME BACK IN TERMS OF
THE REPORT -- TO THE BODIES OF
THE LEGISLATURE TO THE SENATE
YES I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE WERE
JUST DISCUSSING RIGHT -- MISTER --
DALY WAS ASKING ABOUT THEY WILL
COME BACK TO US SO THAT WE CAN
SEE WHAT HAS BEEN DONE.
AND EVALUATE THEM SO TO SPEAK.
I'M SUPPORT YOUR YOUR CONCERN I
HAVE PAUL'S YES OKAY I HAVE
BECAUSE YOU KNOW I'M JUST
CONCERNED SOMEONE TO BRING THAT
TO ATTENTION I THINK IT'S A GOOD
POP APPROACH I THINK IS MOVING
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
AND CERTAINLY -- YOU KNOW
GRATEFUL TO SEE THE COALITION IS
BEHIND THE BILL'S OBVIOUS
SUPPORTING TODAY THANK YOU SOME
OF THE ****.
MR O'DONNELL YEAH I JUST I JUST
START.
ARE YOUR CREW THEN THE STORE. TO
MY FRIEND FROM -- CARSON'S POINT --
WITH REGARD.
TO SOME MISTRUST -- BETWEEN THIS
BODY AND CARP I THINK -- THIS
BILL MAY BE THE ANSWER TO THAT
BECAUSE WHAT'S HAPPENED.
BASICALLY TWO THOUSAND SIX IS
THIS BODY HANDED OVER A LOT OF
POWER TO AN EXECUTIVE AGENCY IN
THAT AS YOU EXECUTIVE AGENCY.
HAS BEEN DOING -- PRETTY MUCH
WHAT THEY WANT WITHOUT POWER
WITHOUT ANY CHECK FROM THIS BODY
AND REALLY THIS BILL IS THIS.
THIS BODIES CHANCE TO STEP UP
AND SAY THIS IS THE FRAMEWORK
FOR THIS PROGRAM THIS IS WHAT WE
WE THE STATE LEGISLATURE WANTED
TO LOOK LIKE THAT'S WHAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING.
WE SHOULD BE WEARING.
IN MORE OFTEN ON CARBS
ACTIVITIES WE SHOULD
RESTRUCTURING THEM.
BECAUSE THIS AND WORK COUNTABLE
TO THEM THEY'RE AND THEY'RE NOT
NECESSARILY ACCOUNTABLE TO US
ALWAYS AND I THINK THIS IS A
THIS IS A GOOD START IN THAT
DIRECTION.
THANK YOU MISTER.
AGES -- ASSEMBLYMEMBER OF YOUR
CREATURES IT'S OKAY.
THANK YOU FOR BEING A FOR IT --
BUT I'M INCLINED TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY.
BUT I THINK THERE'S A LEGITIMATE
ISSUES AND IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES
OF THE FARM BUREAUS RAISING THAT
MUST AND I THINK MUST BE
ADDRESSED IN THE STATUTE -- IF
THEY DON'T IF WE DON'T DO IT
THAT WAY WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
THE CIRCLE WITH KERR -- AND I
JUST WANT TO HOPE YOU'LL COMMIT
TO ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES IN
THE BILL BEFORE IT COMES UP FOR
A VOTE ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
I WILL NOT SUPPORT IF WE DON'T
HAVE THAT CHANGED ABSOLUTELY
FAIR WE DO NOT HAVE A SOLUTION
AT THIS TIME BUT WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED. TO MAKING
SURE WE HAVE A PATH TO
COMPLIANCE I THINK ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT WOULD BE MOST
HELPFUL WOULD BE THE MOBILE UNIT
BUT YES WE ABSOLUTELY SHARE YOUR
CONCERN AND WE WANT TO GET TO A
PATH TO COMPLIANCE SO THAT.
IT WORKS FOR EVERYONE I WORRY
ABOUT -- AS BEING A SMALL FARMER
AND I KNOW WE HAVE A A PIECE OF
MACHINERY.
THAT WE DON'T DRIVE THAT OFTEN
THAT TO GET TO GET TO A SMOG
INSPECTION IS.
LITERALLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR MOBILE
UNIT WOULD BE PERFECT BUT I WANT
TO KNOW THE IT'LL HAPPEN BECAUSE
YOU KNOW PROMISES COULD BE MADE
WE ALL DO APPEAR AND I JUST
THINK THAT I WANT TO MAKE SURE
ALL MY FARMERS ARE TAKING CARE
OF AND I'M HOPING YOU CAN
CONTAIN TO WORK.
WITH FARM BUREAU THE CATALYST
MOVE THAT FOR ABSOLUTELY
APPRECIATE AND RESPECT THAT.
NEAR THE QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE CENTER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
I JUST WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE
STAKE HOLDERS WHO HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THIS PROCESS BECAUSE
THIS IS OUR THIRD YEAR WITH THIS
BILL.
AND EVERYONE HAS BEEN COMMITTED
TO TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
CAN MAKE IT WORK SO I APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S COMMITMENT TO MAKING
SURE WE HAVE CLEAN AIR TO
BREATHE
AND THE AND ALSO MAKING SURE
THAT PRODUCT DOESN'T -- GO TO
THE WAYSIDE AND LIVESTOCK
DOESN'T DIE ON THE SIDE OF THE
ROAD -- FRUITS AND VEGETABLES
DON'T SPOIL ON THE SIDE OF THE
ROAD BUT WE WOULDN'T BE HERE
TODAY IF IT WASN'T FOR
EVERYBODY'S INTENTION TO TRY TO
MAKE THIS WORK I AM ABSOLUTELY
CONFIDENT THAT WE WILL GET TO
WHERE WE NEED TO BE -- WILL BE
PERFECT FOR EVERYONE MAYBE NOT
BUT IF WE ALL WALK AWAY A LITTLE
HAPPY A LITTLE BIT UNHAPPY I
THINK WE CAN GET TO A PLACE THAT
HOPEFULLY EVERYONE CAN SUPPORT
IT.
I GREW UP IN THE EARLY SEVENTIES
IN CHINO I REMEMBER SMOG DAYS I
REMEMBER NOT BEING ABLE TO SEE
THE MOUNTAINS TODAY WE SEE THE
MOUNTAINS MORE OFTEN BUT BECAUSE
THE PARTICULATES ARE SO SMALL.
THEY ARE JUST AS HARMFUL AND WE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT IT SO IT'S A
INCOMING UPON ALL OF US TO WORK
TOGETHER.
AND MAKE A COMMITMENT TO FUTURE
GENERATIONS WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR -- I
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH ALL
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS ON
THIS BILL AND AND AGAIN AS YOU
MENTIONED IN A THREE YEAR
PROCESS.
AND THINK IT'S IMPERATIVE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT.
AND YOU AND YOU MENTIONED ABOVE
THE INDUSTRIES INVOLVED -- THERE
HAS TO BE A BALANCE WE ALL WANT
CLEAN AIR.
BUT HOW DO WE GET TO YES AND I
THINK THE THE ABILITY TO WORK
WITH INDUSTRY THE EXPERTS IN THE
FIELDS AND NOT TELL THEM.
HOW TO COMPLY BUT ASK THEM HOW
THEY CAN COMPLY?
IS IS IMPERATIVE -- WHEN WE LOOK
AT -- YOU KNOW SB.
ONE THE TRUCKING INDUSTRY WAS
ABSOLUTELY IMPERATIVE TO BE ON
WITH THAT BILL SO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY MAINTAIN OUR HIGHWAYS
IN CALIFORNIA AS A PARTNER.
THEY CAN THEY CONTINUE TO BE A
PARTNER IN THIS PROCESS ALSO
WHICH IS ADMIRABLE.
BUT AT WHAT COST DO WE IMPALING
THEM THE TRANSIT INDUSTRY IS AT
HEAVILY SUBSIDIZED BY THE
TRUCKING INDUSTRY.
AND SO WE LOOK AT CLEAN AIR
TRANSIT ALL OF THE THINGS ARE
GOING BUT THEN THE CONSUMER IS
IMPACTED AT SOME POINT.
AND WE ALL END UP PAYING FOR IT
DOWN THE ROAD.
SO I LOVE THIS CAREFUL APPROACH
THAT YOU'RE TAKING.
CONSIDERING ALL THE AVENUES AND
LISTENING TO THE INPUT OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ALSO WHAT AND
HOW IT IMPACTS OF MR GRAYSON
THIS.
YEAR CURRY.
THAT HAS TO BE REMEDIED AGREED
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH THE
FARM INDUSTRY AND CATTLE WAS TO
GO FORWARD.
WITH THAT [inaudible]
WITH THAT.
AFTER THREE YEARS I ABSOLUTELY
DO SUPPORT YOUR BILL THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
AND YOUR STAFF WORKING WITH MY
COMMITTEE ALSO TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE DO ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS.
SO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THANK YOU MISTER.
THE MOTION ISDUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
FRAZIER HI.
FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG NO AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN
[inaudible]
BIGELOW.
LOW NO JUNE.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
DALY.
DALY AYE DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA.
AND I AM IS THERE IN.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I IT IS NINE BELIEVE
ROLE PERHAPS A MEMBERS
CONGRADULATIONS THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
PLEASE IN GERMAN HOW MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE HAD -- TO GO BACK
OVER TO ADD ON IN SESSION SO
WE'LL BE TAKING ABOUT A TEN
MINUTE BREAK -- SO THE THINKING
TO MAKE THEIR VOTES AND COME
BACK.
PLEASE STRETCH YOUR LEGS AND
PLEASE OF EXCUSE THE
INCONVENIENCE
CAN TO SESSION
AFTER A LITTLE RECESS -- SENATOR
BORDERS.
SB [inaudible]
FOUR OH TWO GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SB FOUR OH TWO IS A FIVE YEAR
EXTENSION TO IN YOUR COUNTIES
ADVENTURE TRAIL PILOT PROGRAM.
IN TWENTY ELEVEN A. B. SIX TO
EIGHT ESTABLISH THIS PILOT
PROGRAM WHICH ALLOWED INYO
COUNTY TO DESIGNATE SPECIFIC
COUNTY ROADS AS COMBINED USE
ROUTES FOR OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE
USE.
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO PROGRAM
DELAYS BECAUSE OF LITIGATION.
AND COURT ACTION THERE'S NOT
BEEN ENOUGH TIME FOR A
COMPREHENSIVE EVALUATION OF THE
PILOT PROGRAM.
THE GOALS OF THIS PROGRAM ARE TO
INCREASE TRAFFIC SAFETY IMPROVE
NATURAL RESOURCE PROTECTION.
REDUCE OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE
TRESPASS ON PRIVATE LAND AND
MINIMIZE IMPACTS ON COUNTY
RESIDENTS.
NEITHER THIS BILL NOR THE
EXISTING PILOT PROGRAM.
READ A SINGLE NEW TRAIL OR WROTE
IT DOES HOWEVER CREATE A BETTER
NETWORK OF TRAILS AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY A LEGAL AND
REGULATED MEANS TO ACCESS
EXISTING MAINTAIN TRAILS.
ADDITIONALLY BY HAVING A LINK
TRAIL SYSTEM LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS
THE TOOLS TO PROPERLY DIRECT OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE USERS TO
APPROVED ROUTES AND REDUCE THE
NEED TO POLICE ILLEGAL ACTIVITY.
THIS PROGRAM IS IMPORTANT TO THE
LOCAL ECONOMY.
INYO COUNTY WHICH CONSISTS
PRIMARILY OF HIGH DESERT WITH
WITH LESS THAN 2% PRIVATELY
OWNED LAND.
HAS A ROBUST ATV -- H. B.
COMMUNITY AND RELIES EXTENSIVELY
ON TOURISM DOLLARS.
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
VOTED UNANIMOUSLY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS EXTENSION.
THE BILL HAS ALSO RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
I RESPECTFULLY COLLEAGUES
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON AS
BEFORE -- TO IN ADDITION I AM
JOINED BY INYO COUNTY SHERIFF
JEFF HOLLOW WELL IN PAUL SMITH --
RULE COUNTY REPRESENTATIVE OF RC
RC.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
I AM JEFF FOLLOW CHEF OF INYO
COUNTY I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR TWO AND I'D
LIKE TO MAKE JUST A COUPLE
COMMENTS.
THE VENTURE TRAILS PROGRAM IS
BROAD PUBLIC SUPPORT.
SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS OF AT TEN FORMAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE PUBLIC TO
GIVE TESTIMONY.
AND INTERACT WITH THE BOARD AS
WELL AS THE PLANNING COMMISSION.
AS IT RELATES TO THE ADVENTURE
TRAILS PROGRAM.
THE SHARE SERVICES HAD NO
COMPLAINTS RELATED TO THE
ADVENTURE TRAILS NO TRAIL
PROLIFERATION REPORTED OR
OBSERVED.
NO ACCIDENTS NO LAW ENFORCEMENT
INCIDENTS AND NONE OF THE
PROJECTED OUTCOMES AS DESCRIBED
BY THE OPPONENTS OF THE PROGRAM
OF TAKEN PLACE.
THE REPORTS OF VIOLATIONS -- ON
OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLES THE
SHERIFF'S OFFICE HAVE RECEIVED
INVOLVED IN UNRELATED TO THE
ADVENTURE TRAILS PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM ALLOWS YOU ALWAYS
FOR USERS TO USE EXISTING COUNTY
MAINTAIN ROADS TO ACCESS
CAMPGROUNDS TRAILS IN SERVICES.
IT PROTECTS OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES BY EDUCATING AND
ENCOURAGING OR TO BE USERS TO
RESPECT OUR DISTINCTIVE
LANDSCAPE. THIRTY NINE OF THE
FORTY FOUR MILES -- EXCUSE ME
THIRTY NINE TO FORTY FOUR PROVED
MILES ARE ACTUALLY PAVE ROADS
MAINTAINED BY THE COUNTY THE
REMAINING FIVE MILES ARE ALREADY
APPROVED WRITING YOUR IS -- FOR
EACH FEES.
BY UTILIZING EXISTING ROADS
TROUBLE INFORMATION AND ROSEN IS
REDUCED.
WE ENCOURAGE AND EDUCATE ALWAYS
THREE GROUPS TO PARTICIPATE IN
STORE CHIP PROJECTS FOR THE
FEDERAL AND STATE AGENCIES THAT
CONTROL MUCH OF OUR UNIQUE
LANDSCAPE.
THE PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE EIGHTY PROGRAM IS BEEN
SOLELY FUNDED BY GREEN STICKER
GRANT FUNDING.
NO COUNTY GENERAL FUNDS HAVE
BEEN USED.
THE SMALL SCALE THE PROJECT
SEVEN ROUTES.
HAS LIMITED THE ECONOMIC
BENEFITS BUT WE'RE STARTING TO
SEE INCREASED USE OF THE SYSTEM
PARTICULARLY OF A PRIVATELY
OPERATED CAMPGROUND NEAR BISHOP.
IN CLOSING I WOULD LIKE TO SAY.
A PRIORITY FOR THIS PROJECT HAS
ALWAYS BEEN INFORMING GAUGE OF
PUBLIC IN THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS FOR USE AND
ENJOYMENT OF THE ADVENTURE TRAIL
SYSTEM.
MORE TIME IS NEEDED TO BOTH
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC AND THE VALUE
WITH THE PROGRAM.
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
BEFORE -- TWO AND CONTINUE THE
ADVENTURE TROLLS PILOT PROGRAM
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK THANK YOU NEXT FOR THIS
PLACE TO HIS NAME WOULD BE
REPRESENTING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
PAUL SMITH FROM THE REAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVE CALIFORNIA JUST
BRIEFLY WERE ASKING FOR ANOTHER
EXTENSION BECAUSE DURING THE
LAST -- EXTENSION BILL THAT CAME
THROUGH NOT ALL OF THE TRAILS
HAVE BEEN SANCTIONED AND
COMPLETED AT THAT TIME SO THIS --
TIME PERIOD ALLOWS US TO HAVE A
MORE THOROUGH STUDY THIS IS BEEN
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE FROM ALL OF
OUR MEMBERS WERE IN PARTICULARLY
INYO COUNTY WHICH IS --
OBVIOUSLY A VERY KEEN AS THE
SHERIFF SAID IN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AS WELL AS WRITER
SAFETY AND TRAFFIC SAFETY AS WE
ARE COURAGEOUS BUILT ON THE
FORWARD.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OR SHARE
CONCERNS WITH OTHERS BILL.
PLEASE COME ON P.
STATE YOUR NAME THE REPRESENTING.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS I'M
CATHERINE GARCIA BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA.
EVEN WITH THE AMENDMENTS FROM
THE SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES AND
WATER COMMITTEE CIRCLE
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY OPPOSES
SENATE BILL.
FOUR OH TWO BY EXTENDING THE
POORLY CONCEIVED COMBINED USE
PILOT PROJECT.
UNDER AB SIX TWENTY EIGHT FROM
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN IN IN YOUR
COUNTY.
SET TO EXPIRE ON JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY SETTING IT TO
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THIS BILL
WOULD OPEN OF LAND AND NATURAL
RESOURCES TO POTENTIAL
ENVIRONMENTAL DEGRADATION.
THE INITIAL PILOT PROJECT HAS
GIVEN RISE TO MANY SERIOUS
ISSUES IN IN YOUR COUNTY.
INCLUDING HEALTH AND SAFETY
CONCERNS LICENSING INSURANCE AND
LIABILITY NOISE AND TRAFFIC
INCREASES IN LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
AIR QUALITY IMPACTS FROM DUSTIN
EMISSIONS AND SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
NATURAL RESOURCES.
EXTENDING SUCH A PROGRAM TO
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WILL ONLY
EXACERBATE THESE ISSUES.
AND WHILE WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT
THE SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE AMENDED THE BILL TO
REQUIRE AN INTERIM ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW IT IS WELL DOCUMENTED
THAT -- EACH FEE USE CAN BE
DETRIMENTAL TO RARE AND
IMPERILED SPECIES LIVING ON
NATURAL LANCE AS SUCH WE ASK
THAT THE COMMITTEE VOTE NO ON
THIS BEFORE A TWO THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
LIKE SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
AUTHORS BILL [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
SENATOR WHICH LIKE CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ENSURING
FRAZIER -- I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT --FOR ANY FOLKS
THAT MAY HAVE QUESTIONS ON HOW
COOPERATIVE -- WE HAVE BEEN IN
MAKING CERTAIN THAT -- WE HONOR
A PILOT PROGRAM WHICH IS
PREMISED ON GATHERING
INFORMATION -- WHICH HERE TO
FORCE BEEN STALLED -- WE
VOLUNTEERED IN FACT BROUGHT IT
UP OURSELVES THAT -- FOR THOSE
THAT MIGHT HAVE ANY
ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS THAT WE
WOULD HAVE AN ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW MID TERM UP THE CYCLE AND
THAT PLEASED A LOT OF THE FOLKS
ON THAT HAD SOME CONCERNS.
BUT MY LAST POINT WOULD BE FOR
THOSE FOLKS WHO CARE ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT.
WE CERTAINLY DO FOR THOSE THAT --
THAT -- HAVE HAVE HAD CONCERNS
IN THE PAST.
THE IRONY IS IS THAT BY HAVING
THESE DUAL USE ROADS AND
MAINTAIN CREATING THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM WE ARE IN
FACT.
PROTECTING THE ENVIRONMENT
KEEPING THESE WROTE THESE -- OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLES OUT OF THE
NATURAL SPACE IN IT BRING THEM
BACK INTO -- A MORE REGULATED
ENVIRONMENT.
SO WITH THAT I APPRECIATE -- ON
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT --
THIS -- THIS -- BILL AS BEFORE --
TOO AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
RIGHT.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
SO BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY.
EXTENDING THE O. H. P. PILOT
PROGRAM INTO INYO COUNTY WILL
ALLOW THE COUNTY TO CONTINUE TO
GATHER VALUABLE DATA.
I URGE YOU COUNTY CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH LOCAL RESIDENTS TO BE
AS TRANSPARENT WITH COMMITTEE
THROUGHOUT THE PILOT.
AS A MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE
WHO LOVES GOING OFF ROADING IN
MY FOUR WHEEL DRIVE I APPRECIATE
THE THOUGHTFULNESS.
ABOUT THE DUAL USE -- ROADS IT
IS THE CONCEPT THAT WE SHOULD
AND WILL WORK.
WELL THAT'LL BE VOTING AYE ON
YOUR BILL TODAY MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE [inaudible]
CULTURAL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG I THANK YOUR CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE TIãU RIGHT CHIU
AYE CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY.
DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA. EIGHTY NINE
IS ARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
THAT HAS A WILL LEAVE THE ROLL
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR CAPPIELLO.
SB.
SIX TWENTY EIGHT THIS VERY GOOD
TO SEE YOU AGAIN MY FRIEND.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IT'S GOOD TO
BE BACK.
DEJA VU ALL OVER AGAIN.
MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT SB SIX
TWENTY EIGHT WHICH WAS
AUTHORIZED TO PROCEEDS FROM THE
SALE OF UNUSED PROPERTY
ORIGINALLY PURCHASED FOR THE
PRINT OUT BY PASSED PROJECT IN
MONTEREY COUNTY. TO BE
REALLOCATED FOR RELATED
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENTS
ALONG THE HIGHWAY ONE A ONE
QUARTER IN MONTEREY COUNTY --
LET ME JUST SAY THAT -- THIS
COMMITTEE IS SEEN THIS BILL
BEFORE I WAS VETOED BY THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS A CONTINUATION OF AN
ATTEMPT TO CREATE TRAFFIC
IMPROVEMENTS ALONG HIGHWAY ONE A
ONE IN A RURAL AREA WHERE YOU
HAVE MULTIPLE -- CHALLENGES WITH
LOADED TRUCKS COMING IN OFF OF
THE FIELD ON TO A HIGHWAY WHERE
PEOPLE ARE TRAVELING AT
EXCESSIVE SPEEDS AND SO -- THE
MONEY WOULD BE USED FURTHER ON
DOWN DOWN THE ROADWAY IN IN
ADDITION TO THIS IT'S
RELINQUISHMENT THE BILL INCLUDES
A RELINQUISHMENT OF A HIGHWAY
THAT GOES THROUGH.
THE COMMUNITY THAT REALLY ISN'T
A HIGHWAY ANYMORE IT'S A LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION ROUTE AND SO WITH
THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ALL OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS IN MONTEREY COUNTY
THERE ARE BEEN SIGNIFICANT
DEATHS AND INJURY ALONG THE
HIGHWAY CORD IT NEEDS
IMPROVEMENT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE A WITNESSES SUPPORT.
HELLO.
MY NAME'S DEBBIE ALLEN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY FOR MONTEREY COUNTY AND
WHERE THE SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
ON THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL
REALLY IS TO IMPROVE
TRANSPORTATION SAFETY.
OF SOME YOU MIGHT REMEMBER WHEN
US ONE I WANTED PRUNING AWAY AS
ONE OF THE DEADLIEST STRETCHES
OF HIGHWAY IN THE STATE AND THEY
CALLED IT -- BLOOD ALLEY.
WE PARTNER WITH CALTRANS TO BUY
IT THIS RIGHT AWAY AT TO CREATE
A BY PASS BUT WHEN THE COST OF
THE BY PASS TRIPLED -- WE WORKED
A LESS COSTLY SOLUTION OF
INTERCHANGES AND FRONTAGE ROADS.
THIS LEGISLATION WILL ALLOW US
TO USE THE PRINT OUT BY PASSED
RIGHT AWAY FUNDING. TO ADDRESS
SAFETY ISSUES IN A NEW AND
FORTUNATELY BLOOD ALLEY SECTION
OF ONE A ONE SOUTH THE SALINAS --
IN FACT WE HAVE A CITIZENS GROUP
WHO REPORTS ON THE COLLISIONS --
THEY COME OR BOARD MEETING EVERY
MONTH AND IT SEEMS LIKE THERE'S
A NEW SET OF INJURIES AND
FATALITIES THAT THEY'RE
REPORTING ON AND SHOWING US --
HORRIFIC PICTURES ON SO WE WOULD
LOVE TO BE ABLE TO PUT THE
FUNDING FROM THE OLD FOR NO BY
PASS TO USE IN THE ONE A ONE
CORRIDOR.
SIMILAR LEGISLATION WAS ADOPTED
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR THE
HEY WOULD BY PASS AND FOR THAT
SEVEN TEN CORRIDOR.
AND WE WOULD HOPE TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT AND MONTEREY COUNTY.
BUT WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
RELINQUISHMENT OF HIGHWAY ONE
EIGHTY THREE IN SALINAS -- CITY
OWNERSHIP OF THIS ROAD THROUGH
DOWNTOWN WILL ALLOW FOR TRAFFIC
CALMING AND SAFE -- PEDESTRIAN
CROSSINGS TO A LOCAL SCHOOL AND
TO OUR RAIL STATION THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC'S -- TAKES.
HIS FRIENDS FOR THE AUTHORS BILL
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
REPRESENTING PLEASE THANK YOU
ASHLEY WALKER WITH MATH AND THEN
ON BEHALF OF THE MODERATE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THEY TEST PLANES WERE THE
AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NOT ANY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC THEY LIKE TO USE
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION OR
SHARE CONCERNS WITH THE AUTHORS
BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
SENATE COVER EVER THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING THIS FOR FOR
YEARS WE'VE I'VE DRIVEN THAT
STRETCH IN IT IS.
SO DANGEROUS BUT PRIMARILY WHEN
YOU KNOW HOW OF THE PRODUCE
TRUCKS COMING RIGHT OFF ON THAT
SMALL LITTLE -- ON RAMP IT'S SO
DANGEROUS SO THANK YOU FOR BRING
IT FORWARD LET'S SAVE LIVES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
SHOULD.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY HER A MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO ASK
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE.
CENTER REJECT CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE TODAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU IN AS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
STATED MY PARENTS USED TO LIVE
IN THAT AREA AND I CAN ACTUALLY --
AGREE COMPLETELY I APPRECIATE
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO TO BRING
THAT FORWARD FOR THE PEOPLE YOU
REPRESENT.
WITH THAT'LL BE SPORTING A BILL
TODAY MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE OF
CULTURAL.
THE MOTION IS YOUR PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG I AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
I BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I'D KILL [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA I IN HIS AREA IN
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
THAT IS EIGHT WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE PERHAPS MEMBERS THANK YOU
SENATOR [inaudible]
SIR NUMBER [inaudible] TEN
PLEASE PROCEED WE READY SIR
[inaudible]
AND MEMBERS.
BEFORE YOU TODAY TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL FOUR HUNDRED WHICH
WOULD EXPAND CLEAN MOBILITY
OPTIONS FOR CALIFORNIANS.
THIS BILL WOULD EXPAND THE
PROGRAM CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
INCLUDE ELECTRIC BICYCLES.
ELECTRIC BIKE -- BICYCLE RIDE
SHARING THE BILL WAS SIMPLY A
SINGLE LINE OF CODE TO AN
EXISTING PROGRAM WITHOUT
INCREASING COSTS THE STATE --
THE ADDITION OF P. BIKES AND THE
BIKE BELCHES THIS PROGRAM WOULD
BE HUGELY BENEFICIAL TO THE
ENVIRONMENT.
AND OUR LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
SP FOUR HUNDRED WOULD HAVE
FLEXIBILITY THE PROGRAM GIVE
PARTICIPANTS.
AN INCREASINGLY POPULAR MODE OF
TRANSPORTATION.
CHOOSE FROM A WITH ME HERE TODAY
TO TESTIFY ARE ARE ALL LARA.
IT'LL SKI THE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR
AT THE UC INSTEAD OF
TRANSPORTATION STUDIES MARINE UP
PERSICO E. BIKE USER FROM A CAR
FREE HOUSEHOLD AND CO FOUNDER OF
PEOPLE PROTECTED BIKE LANE
ACTION SAN FRANCISCO.
AND LINDA -- COMMOTION.
FROM A CALIFORNIA BICYCLE
COALITION [inaudible]
EXCEPT THE I THINK THEY'RE
TRYING TO FIVE RIGHT I WAS JUST
KIDDING SO I THINK THEY'RE
TRYING TO FIND A RIGHT HERE.
THERE THERE YES GO AHEAD.
YOUR THE SERB.
I'LL BE QUICK US DEFAULT YOU'RE
ON BEHALF THE CALVARY BY SO
COLLISION WEIRD THAT SPONSOR THE
BILL WE DO URGE YOUR SUPPORT WE
THINK THIS OF RIGHT AN OPTION --
FOR ABILITY FOR FOLKS TO THE
DEAL BY E. BIKES WITH IS
RETURNED -- VEHICLE REBATE SO WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE OTHER
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC LIKE TO TEST
RENTS FOR THE AUTHORS BILL.
THANKS FOR ITS CITY OF LONG
BEACH IN SUPPORT.
BRENDA GARCIA I'M HAVE A CAL
CERTAIN SUPPORT.
AND CALIFORNIA'S THE COASTING
BECAUSE THE SPONSOR AND SUPPORT
THANK.
THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
LIKE TESTIFIES FOR THE AUTHORS
BILLS SEEING NONE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THE LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OR SHARE CONCERNS ON
THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE.
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE OF
THE AUTHOR.
CENTER WAS LIKE CLOSE I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK AND I WILL
THANK YOU SIR -- ABUSE FOR YOUR
BILL TODAY MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS YOUR PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG I THANK YEAR CURRY
[inaudible]
I BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE [inaudible]
TO CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY.
DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA.
DO YOU KNOW I IN THIS AREA
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
IT IS A WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
PERHAPS MEMBERS CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THANK YOU.
OKAY WERE WAITING FOR A I
UNDERSTANDING IS MISTER ALLEN'S
ON HIS WAY CENTER AROUND SO.
WE'LL WAIT. TO FOR A COUPLE
MINUTES [inaudible]
WE BELIEVE [inaudible] ZERO ONE
GOOD TO SEE SIR THANK HERE SO
WE'LL DO -- LET'S TO SB FIFTY
NINE FIRST SIR AND THEN WE'LL GO
TO YOUR SECOND AND TESTING THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR.
WELL LET ME START BY -- THINKING
THE COMMITTEE OF THE CHAIR FOR
ALL THE WORK THAT WAS DONE ON
THIS MEASURE.
YEAH I THINK WE'RE NOW TO PLACE
RELIEF -- GOT TO A COMPREHENSIVE
BILL THAT WE CAN.
ALL BE PROUD OF I'M I'M --
ACCEPTING ALL THE EVENTS IN THE
ARE AND WHICH I THINK WERE
DISTRIBUTED. TO THE COMMITTEE
LATE LAST WEEK -- SO.
NOW THIS HAS TO DO WITH
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES IN THE
INTRODUCTION OF AUTONOMOUS
PASSENGER VEHICLES ONTO OUR
ROADS IN WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES.
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
REVOLUTIONIZE.
THE WAY THAT WE GET AROUND
RECEIVE OUR COMMUNITIES.
NOW THERE'S A LOT OF POTENTIAL
POSITIVES RIGHT THIS INNOVATIVE
TECHNOLOGY COULD DRASTICALLY
REDUCE.
COLLISIONS ENHANCE TRAFFIC FLOW
VERY PROMISING -- BUT I THINK
THERE'S A FEAR THAT IF NOT PROP
AND NOT THOUGHTFULLY DEPLOYED
THIS MOBILITY REVOLUTION.
I COULD HAVE SOME NEGATIVE
IMPACTS SOME SIGNIFICANT EGGMAN
IMPACT INCLUDING EXACERBATING
ALL CALIFORNIA'S ALREADY SEVERE
CLIMATE AIR QUALITY PLANNING AND
CONGESTION.
CHALLENGES.
THE MEDIA ONE EXAMPLE THERE WAS
A AN EXPERIMENT CONDUCTED BY
FOLKS YOU SEE DAVIS BERKELEY.
AND GEORGE ATTACK AND THEY MIMIC
TO LIFE.
WITH THE NAVY -- BASICALLY YOU
KNOW PROVIDING EVERYONE WITH --
EVERY PARTICIPATING HOUSEHOLD
WITH THE SHOW FOR AN EXPERIMENT
SHOWED THAT THE HOUSEHOLDS
TRAVELED. 83% MORE MILES PER
WEEK -- WITH MORE THAN A FIFTH
OF THE VEHICLE TRIPS ACTUALLY
CARRY NO PASSENGERS AT ALL --
BECAUSE IT'S SO CONVENIENT JUST
TO HAVE A DRIVERLESS CAR YOU
KNOW THAT AND AND THE YOU WOULD
YOU BASICALLY USE IT MORE.
AND THEY WOULD OFTEN TIMES --
HAVE THE CAR LOOK JUST CIRCLE
ROUND AND ROUND WAITING FOR THEM
AS OPPOSED TO PARKING -- SO AS
TO BE ABLE TO BE READY AND
AVAILABLE TO PICK THEM UP WHEN
THEY'RE READY TO GO WITHOUT OF
COURSE INCREASED CONGESTION.
SO -- THERE COULD BE SOME
DOWNSIDES TO THIS TECHNOLOGY FOR
NOT SMART ABOUT IT AND I THINK --
WITH ME TO ONE OF THE THINGS WE
WERE LOOKING TO DO WITH SB FIFTY
NINE IS TO CREATE A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH.
TO ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE AND IT
ULTIMATELY THAT THE THE BILL
CREATES THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
THE FUTURE TRANSPORTATION. TO
DELIBERATELY PLANNED FOR
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES IN A WAY
THAT SUPPORTS OUR GOALS IN TERMS
OF SAFETY TRANSPORTATION CLIMATE
SUSTAINABILITY.
SO THIS COUNCIL OF CASTLE BRING
TOGETHER STATE LOCAL AGENCIES --
BRING THEM TOGETHER WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO CRAFT POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WILL THEN
BE DELIVERED TO THE LEGISLATURE
IT'S AN INTENTIONAL PROCESS AND
IT'S OUR HOPE THAT THIS CAN HELP
CALIFORNIA.
RESPONSIBLY GUIDE THE DEPLOYMENT
OF THIS REVOLUTIONARY TECHNOLOGY.
WITH THIS COMMITTEE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH MANY STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING INDUSTRY GROUPS
AUTOMAKERS ENVIRONMENTALISTS
PLANNERS TO REFINE THE MEASURE
ENSURE THAT WE DELIBERATELY --
PLAN WHILE NOT STYMIE.
THIS INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGY SO WE
ALL KNOW THAT WE HAVE TO BEFORE
THINKING WHEN IT COMES THE VIS --
AT THIS BILL ESTABLISHES A
FRAMEWORK TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHENEVER.
THANK YOU HAVE A WITNESSES WORD
SENATOR.
GET EXTENSION IN HERE UPS AND
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CHASTENED BY THOSE AT THE UNION
OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS -- HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BELL AT SELF
DRIVING CARS MAY BE THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT INNOVATION
TRANSPORTATION SINCE THE
INVENTION OF THE AUTOMOBILE.
AND THOUGH STILL IN THEIR
INFANCY -- THESE VEHICLES COULD
RADICALLY TRANSFORM HOW PEOPLE
AND GOODS MOVE AROUND WITH
PROFOUND IMPLICATIONS GOOD OR
BAD. FOR SAFETY EQUITY IN THE
ENVIRONMENT.
AND IT'S TIME FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO ASSESS THE
OPPORTUNITIES AND RISKS.
THIS TECHNOLOGY PRESENTS
DETERMINE THE FORWARD LOOKING
POLICIES THAT WILL BE NEEDED TO
STEER AVISA POSITIVE DIRECTION.
HI SO I THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS WERE PARTICULARLY
FOCUSED ON ADDRESSING THE
CLIMATE CRISIS AND ARE LOOKING
AT THE RULES THAT EIGHTIES WILL
PLAY -- IN THAT AND AS WITH MANY
ASPECTS OF THIS TECHNOLOGY WE
SEE BOTH RISKS AN OPPORTUNITY --
AND SO WE ARE PARTICULAR GLAD TO
THE BILL WITH THE AMENDMENTS
BEING TAKEN TODAY WILL RETAIN A
KEY FOCUS ON ISSUES OF POLLUTION
CONGESTION.
THROUGH A SUBGROUP DEVOTED TO
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND BUILDING HEALTHY
AND SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE ASK YOU
SUPPORT SB THIRTY NINE TODAY
THANKS THANK YOU SO MUCH OF THE
OTHER.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL.
MEREDITH ALEXANDER ON BEHALF OF
CAL START IN SUPPORT IN
PARTICULAR OF THE ELEMENT JUST
MENTIONED -- MAINTAINING THE SUB
GROUP CHAIRED BY OPR TO LOOK AT
POTENTIAL ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
OF THOMAS VEHICLES.
WE BELIEVE THIS IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO MAKING SURE THE
TECHNOLOGY DOESN'T EXACERBATE
EXISTING ISSUES RELATED TO
CLIMATE CHANGE.
AIR POLLUTION AND SPRAWL THANK
YOU.
IT IS THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
LIKE TESTIFIED SUPPORT OF THE
OTHERS BILL [inaudible]
X..
BETSY FACTORED FOSSEL FREE
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR ALAN THANK YOU.
MR TERAKHIR CHILD DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE HAVE NO
POSITION ON THE BILL BUT WE
WOULD LIKE.
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING ON THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WOULD INCLUDE DISABILITY RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS ON THE COUNCIL IN
THAT INDEED THE RECOMMENDATIONS
WILL LOOK AT ACCESSIBLE MOBILITY
OPTIONS THANK YOU -- MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS TIM CHIANG
THAT THE AUTO CLUB OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AS AMENDED.
THANK YOU.
HELLO SANTA BRUSO I'M DOT THOMAS
EAGLE POLICY MANAGER WITH
TRIPOLI NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
NEVADA AND UTAH AND WE SUPPORT
THE BILL AS AMENDED.
SO HIS ONLY SHAUN BEHALF OF
ADVANCED ENERGY ECONOMY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THE OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE THERE WAS A PUBLIC
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OR
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE AUTHORS
BILL MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAPPED
OUT FOR THE TEAMSTERS IN THEM
OUT MADE TRANSIT UNION JUST HERE
TO AT REMOVER OPPOSITION TODAY
THANK YOU.
MR TURN MEMBERS CORNING JOHNSON
WITH TECH MATT AND WE WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND THIS
COMMITTEE FOR THE I AM OUT OF
WORK THAT THEY'VE DONE ON THIS
BILL -- WILL ALSO BE LOOKING TO
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION WHEN THE
AMENDMENTS GO INTO PRINT -- YOU
KNOW WE REALLY JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE WITH THIS BILL THAT WE ARE
LOOKING AT AB IS FROM EIGHT YOU
KNOW TRANSPORTATION HOLISTIC
ANGLE AND THAT WE'RE SUPPORTING
CONTINUE DEVELOPMENT OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY -- IN THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE HAS ALSO
ASKED ME TO ECHO OUR COMMENTS.
THANK YOU THE QUEUE.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIANA VALENTINE
ON BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE OF
AUTOMOBILE MANUFACTURERS ALSO
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION WITH THE
AMENDMENTS TODAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THAT THE EFFORT.
THANK YOU.
HE KNEW THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC FEEL LIKE TO TEST FINE
OPPOSITION OR SHARE CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE CENTER WAS LIKE
CLOSE.
ALL THE HARD WORK THAT WE DID
TOGETHER IT WAS -- WE GOT WE LOT
OF BACK AND FORTH BUT I THINK WE
GOT TO GET PLACE AND I I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE THAT THE HARD WORK
IN THE CHAIRAND COMMITTEE IN.
AND MY STAFF AND AND THE
SUPPORTERS AND AND ALL THE FOLKS
WHO -- THIS THE FROM TODAY THE
STAKEHOLDERS -- SO I THINK THIS
IS GOING TO TAKE US IN A REALLY
GOOD DIRECTION TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND.
THIS CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE --
WITH REGARDS TO FUTURE
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING WHAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK ME ABOUT THE
CENTER AND I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THE DIALOGUE YOU AND
I HAD PLUS THE CAN THE PASSION
AND COMPASSION THAT OUR STAFF.
HAS A LOVE FOR THIS -- POLICY
MATTER CAN'T THINK DAVID ENOUGH
IN YOUR STAFF MEMBER. FOR THE
THE DIALOGUE AND AND MAKING SURE.
IN OVER.
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND AMERICANS
HAVE DIED IN THE ROAD THE LAST.
EIGHTEEN YEARS ONE OF THOSE WITH
MY DAUGHTER.
AND AUTOMATED VEHICLES IF
DEPLOYED CORRECTLY WELL THE
POTENTIAL TO SAVE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF LIVES ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS.
THE CDC SERVICES ADVISORY BODY
TO THE LEGISLATURE ON
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES.
IN YOUR HOUSE CENTER BELL SO
SERVES ON THAT IN THE EXHIBITION
I SERVED.
IN THE EX OFFICIO FOR THE
ASSEMBLY.
AND I FIRMLY BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THEY CONVENE A
TASK FORCE TO INFORM THE
LEGISLATURE FROM POLICIES WE MAY
NEED TO CONSIDER ALSO.
HENCE WITHOUT AND AGAIN I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE US HAVING THE
ABILITY TO TALK TOGETHER AND
WORK TOOL HOW DO WE GET TO YES --
AND I'LL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
TODAY THANK YOU.
MA'AM SIR TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL -- I DO ME MOTIONS.
HEY BUDDY.
THE BILL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN.
AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY--
WITH THAT PLEASE -- CULTURAL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
COMMUNICATIONS AND CONVEYANCE.
FRAZIER AYE FRAZIER AYE FONG
ANOTHER [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
I BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING CHIPS ARE.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN.
HI FRIEDMAN I GIPSON
[inaudible]
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA.
DâN I IN THIS AREA [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING CHIME.
IS THERE AN O'DONNELL.
THE BILL HAS EIGHT IT'S CONTROLS
CAN BE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS -
WOULD LIKE TO MOVE ON TO SB.
SIX SIX FOUR SEVEN THANK YOU
ABOUT WHAT ONCE AGAIN -- ONE I
THINK THE CONSULTANTS -- IN BOTH
OF THE PARTIES AT THIS COMMITTEE
THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE.
AS WELL FOR THE HARD WORK ON
THIS BILL -- I'M VERY HAPPY TO
TAKE A PROPOSED MMA WHICH I
RIVER IT'S CURRENT LANGUAGE
REGARDING PHOTOGRAPHIC EVIDENCE
AND HOT HI HI.
YOU KNOW I I COULD SEE TOLL
LANES TO EXACTLY AS A REASON
CURRENT LAW.
AND I ALSO -- COMMITTEE WORKING
WITH THIS COMMITTEE THROUGH THE
CHAIR AND STAFF TO REFINE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL -- THAT --
REFINED REFINING WHICH IN THE
BILL THE SUFFICIENTLY ADDRESSED
CONCERNS RAISED BY PROPOSED
AMENDMENT BE.
I AGREE THAT -- THE NOTICES OF
TOLL FEES AND FINES SHOULD BE
SUFFICIENT SO DRIVERS ARE
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES ARE AWARE OF
ANY CHANGE CHARGES IN A TIMELY
MANNER.
YOU CAN PAY WHAT THEY OWE I I
THINK THAT YOU'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR STAFF AND
OUR WORKING OUT -- THAT.
THAT ISSUE -- SO.
THE GROUP OF IN A GOOD DIRECTION
TOGETHER.
SO MEMBERS CALIFORNIA'S REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES BUILD
OPERATE AND MAINTAIN ROADS
BRIDGES AND TRANSIT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND SERVICES ON BEHALF OF THE
PUBLIC SO THIS BILL AFFIRMS THAT
THESE AGENCIES HAVE CLEAR
AUTHORITY. TO RESPONSIBLE USE
PERSONAL INFORMATION FOR
NECESSARY DAY TO DAY ACTIVITIES
TO OPERATE TOLLS AND REGIONAL
TRANSIT SYSTEMS ON THE PUBLIC'S
BEHALF.
HERE'S HOW WE COME TO THIS ISSUE
OVER RECENT MONTHS A GROWING
LIST OF LITIGANTS.
SOME PETITIONING FOR CLASS
ACTION STATUS HOW FILED CLAIMS
AGAINST REGIONAL TOLL AGENCIES
AND CONTRACTORS CALIFORNIA.
ALLEGING VIOLATIONS THAT IMPERIL
BILLIONS IN TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
NOW THERE'S BEEN SOME LAWSUITS
THAT MAKE BROAD ASSERTIONS OF
FEDERAL AND STATE CONSTITUTIONAL
VIOLATIONS WHICH COURTS HAVE. TO
DATE LARGELY BRUSHED ASIDE --
BUT BUT PLEASE ALSO POINT TO
MILLIONS OF REPORTED INDIVIDUAL
VIOLATIONS OF STREETS AND
HIGHWAYS SECTION.
CODE SECTION THIRTY ONE FOR
NINETY WHICH WAS ESTABLISHED IN
TWENTY TEN THROUGH LEGISLATION
AUTHORED BY SENATOR JOSEPH
MEDIAN THIS IS SB.
TWELVE SIXTY EIGHT NOW THE WELL
DOCUMENTED INTENT A SENTENCE TO
MILLIONS BILL WAS TO CODIFY
UNIFORM STANDARDS ACROSS ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S.
TOTALING AGENCIES TO PROTECT
AGAINST PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION OF CONSUMERS BEING
PROVIDED TO COMPANIES
ORGANISATIONS FOR MARKETING OR
INAPPROPRIATE USES THAT WAS THE
GOAL IN FACT YET IS A FACT SHEET
THAT WE TRACKED DOWN FROM -- THE
THE TIME WHEN HE WAS -- GIVEN
THE BILL PASSED.
TWENTY TEN ANY DETAILS HOW THE
BILL WAS CRAFTED TO NOT HINDER A
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY FROM
FINANCIAL ACTIVITIES REQUIRED TO
OPERATE AND MANAGE TOLL
FACILITIES INCLUDING THE SHARING
OF DATA. TO ENSURE INTER
OPERABILITY OF TOLL COLLECTION
DEVICES AND TECHNOLOGIES.
NOW -- BECAUSE THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL APPLY RETROACTIVELY
AND WHAT IMPACT PENDING
LITIGATION IT REALLY DOES
DESERVE SCREENING FROM LAWMAKERS.
I TO ENSURE THAT ITS INTENT IS
IN WITH THE PUBLIC INTERESTED IN
LINE WITH -- SB. TWELVE SIXTY
EIGHT SERIES CONSUMER INJURIES
CAN AND DO OCCUR WHEN SENSITIVE
AND PRIVATE INFORMATION IS
SHARED FOR MARKETING OR
INAPPROPRIATE PURPOSES.
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
GET OUT HERE RIGHT WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE NOT LETTING
CORPORATIONS OFF THE HOOK FOR
FAILING TO PROTECT YOUR CREDIT
CARD DATA.
COMPANIES A FREE PASS FOR
PROFITING FROM USERS MEDICAL
HISTORY INSTEAD THE BILL DEFENDS
THE VITAL PUBLIC INTEREST THE
OPERATION AND MAINTENANCE OF A
COMPREHENSIVE.
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
AND I THINK FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
ABSENT CLEAR EVIDENCE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S ARE BETTER OFF OF
MILLIONS OF OF BILLIONS OF TAX
DOLLARS ARE IMPERILED -- FOR FOR
THE SORTS OF VIOLATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP BY THESE --
BY THESE CASES
I SB SIX SIXTY FOUR PROVIDES AN
IMPORTANT AND NECESSARY
CLARIFICATION OF STATE LAW TO
CONTINUE ALLOWING TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES TO USE PERSONAL DATA
EFFICIENTLY RESPONSIBLY WHILE
MAINTAINING APPROPRIATE
PROHIBITIONS AGAINST IMPROPER
SHARING ABOUT INFORMATION I
THINK THAT.
THE ISSUES THAT WE WORKED OUT
WITH THE COMMITTEE HELP TO
ENSURE THAT THE BILL CERTAINLY
ALSO IF PASSED OUT OF COMMITTEE
TODAY WILL GO TO PRIVACY.
COMMITTEE WHERE -- WHERE WILL
CONTINUE TO HONE THOSE
PROTECTIONS OF OF CONSUMERS AND
WITH ME HERE TODAY WE HAVE
REBEKAH LONG FROM THE MATCH ONE
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION MTC?
AND ALSO CENTRAL JOHNSON WHO IS
THE CHIEF TOLL OPERATIONS
OFFICER FOR THE TRANSPORTATION
CORRIDOR AGENCIES OF ORANGE
COUNTY.
AND SHARE THE CALIFORNIA TOLL
OPERATORS COMMITTEE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS I THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR FOR
ALLOWING US TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
I'M AS WAS NOTED MY NAME IS
SAMUEL JOHNSON I'M CHIEF TOLD
OPERATIONS OFFICER.
I HAD A TRANSPORTATION QUARTER
AGENCIES IN ORANGE COUNTY.
I ALSO SERVE AS THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA TOLL OPERATORS
COMMITTEE OR SEE TOP.
I SEE TALK IS THE COALITION OF
THE FOURTEEN PUBLIC AGENCIES
RESPONSIBLE FOR TOLLING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
I AM ALSO THE INCOMING PRESIDENT
FOR THE INTERNATIONAL BRIDGE
TUNNEL IN TURN PIKE ASSOCIATION
WHICH SERVES THE GLOBAL TOWING
INDUSTRY WITH TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
MEMBERS ACROSS TWENTY THREE
COUNTRIES.
IN ACCORDANCE WITH CALIFORNIA
LAW CALTRANS WORK WITH C. TIME
TO DEVELOP STATEWIDE INTER
OPERABILITY STANDARDS FOR TOLD
AGENCIES TO PROCESS TOLL
PAYMENTS.
SEE TALK ALSO PARTNERS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES IN
UTILIZES THEIR STANDARDS FOR
IDENTIFYING VEHICLE OWNERS AND
REINFORCING THE PAYMENT OF TOLLS.
ARE AGENCIES COLLABORATED WITH
SENATORS MANY ITS OFFICE ON THE
LANGUAGE AND SB TWELVE SIXTY
EIGHT TO ENSURE THE PROPER
HANDLING OF PERSONAL DATA.
THE TOLD ME AGENCIES HAVE IT
HERE TO THE LAW AND ITS INTENT
AND THERE'S BEEN NO BREACHES OF
PRIVACY.
SALES OF CUSTOMER DATA OR
CONSUMER HARM FROM AGENCIES TONY
OPERATIONS.
HOWEVER CLARIFICATIONS IN THE
LAW ARE NEEDED TO COMBAT FALSE
ASSERTIONS AROUND MISCONCEIVED
GRAY AREAS -- IN THE LANGUAGE OF
THE ASSERTIONS PUT FOR CALL INTO
QUESTION THE DAY TO DAY
OPERATING ACTIVITIES AND
PRACTICES OF OUR AGENCIES.
AND THREATEN OUR MEMBERS WITH
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN FINES FOR DOING SIMPLE THINGS
SUCH AS COMMUNICATING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES TO
GET SOMEONE'S ADDRESS TO MAIL
THEM A NOTICE.
COMPLYING WITH STATE MANDATED
INTER OPERABILITY BY SHARING
INFORMATION NEEDED TO PROVIDE A
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT OR A
CUSTOMER WITH A SINGLE ACCOUNT
THAT THEY CAN YOU STATE WHY. FOR
USING THE US POSTAL SERVICE FOR
MAILING NOTICES.
FROM USING VENDORS TO SUPPORT
OUR SYSTEMS AND AND PROCESS
TOLLS.
AND THEN PLAYING BOTH SIDES OF
THE COIN PLAINTIFFS ATTORNEYS
HAVE ALSO CLAIM THAT WE VIOLATE
THE LAW WE WE CONDUCT A SKIP
TRACE TO FIND THE CORRECT
ADDRESS FOR USER.
WHILE ALSO CLAIMING THAT WE
VIOLATE THE LAW WHEN WE DON'T DO
A SKIP TRACE TO FIND THE CORRECT
ADDRESS FOR A FOR A VEHICLE
OWNER.
SB SIX SIXTY FOUR WOULD CLEAR
CLEAR UP THESE GRAY AREAS AND
CAUGHT A FIVE ORIGINAL INTENT.
OF THE LAW WHILE RETAINING
PROTECTIONS FOR PRIVACY ALLOWING
US TO PERFORM OUR DAILY%
FUNCTIONS THAT ARE BEST
PRACTICES IN THE TOWING INDUSTRY --
THIS BILL CONTINUES -- THE
SUPPORT OF TOLLING AS A VIABLE
REVENUE SOURCE USED TO ENHANCE
MOBILITY MAKE IMPROVEMENTS TO
THE STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM.
AND ENHANCETRANSIT OPERATIONS
AS WELL AS SUPPORT CRITICAL
SAFETY FUNCTIONS PERFORMED BY
THE CHP.
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA'S TOLL
OPERATORS I REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT
FOR SB [inaudible] SIX SIXTY
FOUR SEVEN GOOD AFTERNOON I
CHAIR FRAZIER VICE CHAIR FONG
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS REBECCA
LONG AND I'M THE MANAGER OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR THE BAY
AREA TOLL AUTHORITY OR ABOUT IT.
THAT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR TOLL
COLLECTION ON THE BAY AREA SEVEN
STATE OWNS TOLL BRIDGES WHICH
CARRY ABOUT THREE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND DAILY TRIPS.
THAT ALSO ADMINISTERS CUSTOMER
SERVICE FOR THE OLD OTHER TOLL
SYSTEMS IN THE REGION INCLUDING
THE GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE AND A
GROWING NETWORK OF EXPRESS LANES.
ARE TOLL BRIDGES AND EXPRESS
LANES ARE THE ARTERIES OF THE
REGION'S TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM
AND HOLES ARE THE REVENUE SOURCE
USED TO OPERATE AND MAINTAIN THE
BRIDGES THEMSELVES.
PAY DOWN DEBT SERVICE ON PRIOR
IMPROVEMENTS AND FUND VOTER
APPROVED MEASURES LIKE REGIONAL
MEASURE THREE A TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TOLL INCREASE WHICH FUNDS
BOTTLENECK IMPROVEMENTS ON THE I
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY INTERCHANGE
AND SOLANO COUNTY.
THE MARINES NEWMAN NARROWS AND
IMPROVE ACCESS TO SILICON VALLEY
AMONG MANY OTHER PROJECTS.
SB SIX SIX FOUR WILL PROTECT
HOLES PAID BY LAW ABIDING
MOTORISTS FOR THESE INTENDED
PURPOSES RATHER THAN ON
DEFENDING -- MERITLESS
LITIGATION AS THE LIKE OF WHAT
YOU'VE JUST HEARD DESCRIBED BY
MY COLLEAGUE SAMUEL.
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN THE
AUTHOR ON THE STAFF ON WORKING
ON THIS BILL WE UNDERSTAND THERE
HAVE BEEN CONSUMPTION CERN'S
ABOUT SOME PROVISIONS AND WE'RE
JUST COMMITTED TO WORKING ON
THOSE -- AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD AND I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
ANYONE MAY HAVE.
PUBLIC THAT HAVE ANY QUICK --
SUPPORT OF THE AUTHORS BILL
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
STATE YOUR NAME HERE
REPRESENTING PLACE.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS ENTRY ENTRY ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY WE THANK THE AUTHOR
VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND WE SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS MICHAEL
PENN TELLER THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION FOR THE
REASONS PREVENT PREVIOUSLY
STATED WE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER TRUST BUT
THEN PASSED THE SAME BERNIE OKAY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY AND
SANTA CLARA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MORE
TOP ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
AN ORANGE COUNTY BUSINESS
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JEREMY SMITH YOUR BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ALSO IN SUPPORT.
A DEFINITE STEVE WALKER ABOUT
THE GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE DISTRICT
ALSO SUPPORT.
CORNELIUS BURKE WITH THE BEAR
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
STEVE BAKER WITH THEIR NEED
ASSISTANCE FOR THE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT IN SUPPORT -- MISTER
CHAIRMAN RICHARD HARRIS FROM THE
NORSEMAN FIRM ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO -- BAY AREA WATER
EMERGENCY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
HAVE -- WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE AUTHORS BILL
OR WILSHIRE CONCERNS PLEASE
SUPPORT.
PLEASE TO JAMIE REPRESENT PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- RICHARD HALL
OVER WITH THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
DO APPRECIATE THE WORK OF OF THE
COMMITTEE.
TO CRAFT SOME PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS THAT WE THINK START
TO MOVE IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
ALTHOUGH THERE CERTAINLY.
OF MORE WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE ON THOSE AMENDMENTS THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA WORKED VERY CLOSELY
WITH US SENATOR SYMMETRY IN.
BACK IN TWENTY TEN AT THAT TIME --
THERE WERE MANY CONCERNS BEING
RAISED ABOUT THE PRIVACY OF
INFORMATION GATHERED FROM
MOTORISTS WHO SUBSCRIBE TO
ELECTRONIC TOLL COLLECTION
SYSTEMS.
AND THESE HAVE ONLY CONTINUE TO
GROW IN THEIR DOMINANCE AROUND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
OF THESE SYSTEMS HAVE ACCESS TO
VERY VERY PERSONAL INFORMATION.
NAME ADDRESS EMAIL OF PHONE
NUMBERS CREDIT CARD OR BANK
ACCOUNT INFORMATION AND AS YOU
TRAVEL THE ROADS.
THE LOCATIONS THAT YOUR TRAVEL
SAVE GEOLOCATION INFORMATION AND
THEY HAVE TRAFFIC PATTERN
INFORMATION THIS IS SENSITIVE
INFORMATION.
THAT WAS BEING.
USED IMPROPERLY SO -- WE
SUPPORTED US SENATE BILL TWELVE
SIXTY EIGHT AND I WANT TO NOTE
THAT SEVERAL OF THE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES
INITIALLY OPPOSED THAT BILL.
AND WHEN MR SO MEDIAN --
EXCERPTED AMENDMENTS THAT
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS THAT
MAINLY DEALT WITH THE LENGTH OF
TIME THAT THESE RECORDS ARE
RETAINED.
THEY DROP THEIR OPPOSITION THE
BILL HAD NO OPPOSITION IN THIS
FINAL FORM IT WAS.
APPROVED WITH STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND SIGNED INTO LAW BY
GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER SO.
OF WE ARE CONCERNED WITH SEVERAL
ASPECTS OF THE BILL.
THAT AFFECT PRIVACY UNDER
CURRENT LAW.
OF IN ORDER -- FOR A TOLLING
AGENCY TO USE OR SHARE YOUR
INFORMATION IT REQUIRES A
WRITTEN.
CONSENT AN OPT IN CONSENT THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD CHANGE WOULD
IN ADDITION TO THAT WRITTEN UP
AND ESTABLISH AN ELECTRONIC
OPTED.
AND I'M SURE MANY OF YOU HAVE
USED EITHER CELL PHONES OR OTHER --
MOBILE DEVICES TO SIGN UP FOR
VARIOUS KINDS OF SERVICES AND
PRODUCTS AND USUALLY YOU GOT TO
SCROLL THROUGH FORTY FIFTY PAGES
OF LEGAL GOBBLEDYGOOK THAT
NOBODY READS.
AND EMBEDDED IN THAT IS THE
OFTEN SO PEOPLE DO NOT READ
THOSE ELECTRONIC CONSENT FORMS
WE'VE WORKED ON OTHER BILLS
TRYING.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE OPT IN
CONSENT IS A SEPARATE ACT FROM
THIS THE ACT OF SIGNING UP FOR
THE SERVICE BUT TYPICALLY IT IS
EMBEDDED AND NO ONE BOTHERS TO
LOOK TO FIGURE OUT HOW.
TO UNCHECK THE OPTION SO THERE'S
A PROBLEM WITH THAT.
THE THE OTHER PROBLEM WE HAVE IS
IT REVERSES THE ENFORCEMENT
SCHEME.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE OF
VIOLATION OF SOMEONE'S PRIVACY
HAS ENUMERATED MONETARY DAMAGES
THIS IS ONE OF SEVERAL LAWS.
THAT PROVIDE FOR MONETARY
DAMAGES AND IN MISTER ALLEN'S OF
STATEMENT THAT THIS DOES NOT
AFFECT MEDICAL PRIVACY WILL OF
COURSE IT IS NOT BECAUSE THESE
AGENCIES DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
THAT INFORMATION HOWEVER. ONE
POINT OUT OF OUR RELATIONS
SOMEONE'S MEDICAL PRIVACY UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW SUBJECTS THE THE
THE VIOLATOR TO ENUMERATED
MONETARY DAMAGES AND MISTER
ALLEN ALSO SAID HE DOESN'T
CREDIT CARD PRIVACY.
AGAIN THE SONG BEVERLY CREDIT
CARD ACT WHICH COVERS CREDIT
CARD PRIVACY DOES ALSO ENUMERATE
MONETARY DAMAGES SERVICE SO YOU
TO WRAP IT UP OKAY SO THE
REVERSAL OF THAT SCHEME WOULD A
RADIC KATE THE ACCESS TO JOBS AS
MOST IMPORTANT THOUGH I WANT TO
POINT OUT.
RETROACTIVITY IS A VERY VERY
SERIOUS MATTER IS POINTED OUT IN
THE UP IN THE ANALYSIS THIS IS
AN EFFORT TO IMPACT CURRENT
PENDING LITIGATION BY SAYING
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK EIGHT
YEARS AND REYES THE RULES UNDER
WHICH THESE AGENCIES.
OF WERE EXPECTED TO OPERATE WE
CAN HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT
GOING FORWARD LOOKING AT CHANGES
THAT NEED TO BE MADE BUT TRYING
TO RETRO.
ACTIVELY REYES EIGHT YEARS OF
THE WAR YOU KNOW THAT THE LAW IS
JUST A AN ABSOLUTELY HORRENDOUS
WAY TO APPROACH LAWMAKERS THANK
YOU THANKS WITH THIS PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME HERE
REPRESENTING PLACE.
MY NAME IS ADAM GOT RIDE.
OF I AM A LAWYER FOR A COURT
APPOINTED CLASS OF MOTORISTS IN
CALIFORNIA WHO'VE BEEN CHARGED
TOLL VIOLATIONS.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THE MOST
NOTICES THAT WERE SENT TO THEM
WERE RETURNED UNDELIVERABLE AS
ADDRESSED.
AND MY OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
TODAY HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THESE PRIVACY CONCERNS THAT
YOU'VE HEARD SO MUCH ABOUT BUT
FOCUSES ENTIRELY ON THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS TO VEHICLE CODE
SECTION -- FOR TWO FIVE FOUR
WHICH WAS ADDED BY AN ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT BILL NOT IN TWO
THOUSAND TEN BUT IN TWO THOUSAND
AND TWO AT THAT.
SECTION OF THE BILL REQUIRES THE
TOWING AGENCIES TO USE THE PAST
EFFORTS TO FIND AN UPDATED
ADDRESS WHEN THE MALES RETURNED
UNDELIVERABLE.
WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW --
BUT IS THAT SEVERAL TOLL
AGENCIES WHEN THEY WE GET THESE
MAIL NOTICES RETURNED
UNDELIVERABLE IS THAT THEY DO
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING WITH THEM.
AND THAT TOLL VIOLATIONS ARE
ACCRUING EVEN THOUGH IT'S KNOWN
TO THE AGENCIES THAT THE MAIL
WAS NOT DELIVERED.
THE LEGISLATIVE HISTORY EXPLAINS
THAT THE PURPOSE OF THE BEST
EFFORTS REQUIREMENT IN THE TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO STATUTE WAS --
TO WAS SPECIFICALLY TO DEAL WITH
THE SITUATION WHERE THE DMV.
DOES NOT HAVE A CURRENT ADDRESS
OF THE MOTORIST.
AND SO.
THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE PROPOSED
THAT ARE SORT OF DROPPED INTO
THIS BILL WHICH MOSTLY CONCERNS
OTHER ISSUES BUT THE PROPOSED.
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS TO THE
EXISTING LAW AND SB.
SIX FOUR FOUR WHICH IS THIS RATE
THAT REQUIREMENT THAT THE
AGENCIES USE THEIR BEST EFFORTS
BY REPLACING IT WITH A VERY
VAGUELY WORDED PROVISION THAT.
RELYING ON THE DMV IS PRIMA
FACIA EVIDENCE OF PAST EFFORTS.
AND THAT OPENS A WHOLE HOST OF
PROBLEMS.
THAT ARE GOING TO BE FACED IN
FURTHER LITIGATION AS TO WHAT IT
WOULD MEAN.
IN THE CONTEXT OF MY CASE FOR
EXAMPLE WHEN YOU HAVE.
NOTICE TO THE AGENCIES THAT THE
ADDRESS THAT THE MAIL IS NOT
BEING DELIVERED.
THE STAFF OF THIS COMMITTEE HAS.
A PROPOSED TO ALL OF THE MEMBERS
THAT AMENDMENTS BEING MADE TO SB
SIX FOUR FOUR TO ACCOUNT FOR
THIS SPECIFIC ISSUE.
AND THAT IS THAT THEY WOULD
REQUIRE THE AGENCIES TO TAKE-SPECIFIC ACTIONS WHEN MAIL IS
RETURNED.
I'M SO FAR SENATOR ALLEN HAS NOT
AGREED TO THOSE AMENDMENTS BUT
AT WHAT HE SAID EARLIER WAS THAT
HE WOULD AGREE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE -- AND WE WOULD
WELCOME THE CONTINUING
INVOLVEMENT OF THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE ON HAVING THOSE
AMENDMENTS AND WOOD I OPPOSE THE
BILL UNLESS.
THEY ARE AMENDED AS THE
COMMITTEE STAFF HAS RECOMMENDED
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITH
THIS PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME.
AND WHO REPRESENTING IN THE IF
YOU'RE IN COMPLETE AGREEMENT
WITH THE OTHER WITNESSES PLEASE
SHISEIDO.
MR TEAR MEMBERS ROSE MERRY
SHAMPOOS AND CONSUMERS FOR AUTO
RELIABILITY SAFETY WE SHARE THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE OTHER
OPPONENTS BUT LEAVING MONTHS
RESPECTFULLY ALSO OPPOSE THE
BILL.
AND I WOULD JUST NOTE -- THAT IN
THE ANALYSIS THE ANALYSIS STATES
THE CHANGES AN EVIDENTIARY
BURDEN THE REDUCTION IN WHAT
CONSTITUTES BEST EFFORT THE
CAPPING OF DAMAGES SEEM TO STACK
THE DECK AGAINST THE WRONGFULLY
ACCUSED CITIZEN.
IN FAVOR TRANSPORTATION AGENCY
AND WE HEAR ON A REGULAR BASIS
FROM YOUR CONSTITUENTS WHO ARE
HAVING TROUBLE WITH THEIR
VEHICLE REGISTRATION AND JUST
GETTING THE VEHICLES REGISTERED
IN THEIR OWN NAME AND IN
COMMUNICATIONS.
PEOPLE DO NOT ALWAYS
UNFORTUNATELY GET NOTICED WHEN
THERE'S A A TOLL VIOLATION AND
FOR PEOPLE TO LOSE THEIR CAR.
WHICH IS WHAT TOO OFTEN HAPPENS
WHEN THERE ARE PROBLEMS -- AND
THEY HAVEN'T PAID THEIR TOLD.
FOR A LOT OF CALIFORNIANS THAT
MEANS THEIR LIFE BASICALLY FALLS
APART SO WE NEED TO BE CAREFUL
ON IN IN WHAT WE ALLOW THE TOLL
AGENCIES TO DO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU YOU THE
WITNESSES PLEASE TEACH NAME
YOU'RE REPRESENTING PLEASE.
FROM MISTER CHAMBERS AT NAS YOUR
HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK OR TURN
WERE OPPOSE WE DO ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO LOOK AT TWO ISSUES
THAT WERE NOT REYES WHICH IS --
IT THIS BILL WILL ALLOW THE
COLLECTION OF PHONE NUMBERS FOR
DRIVERS WHICH WE BELIEVE ISN'T
ALLOWED UNDER CURRENT LAW.
AND ALSO CREATES A NEW STANDARD
FOR PRIME APHASIA EVIDENCE OF A
VIOLATION OF A TOLL OF A TOLL
VIOLATION -- RETROACTIVE WHICH
MEANS DRIVERSWHO AREN'T IN
VIOLATION TODAY FOR SOMETHING
THEY DID LAST YEAR MAY BE IN
VIOLATION IF THIS BILL PASSES
FOR SOMETHING YOU DID LAST YEAR
THOSE ARE TWO ISSUES THAT NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED I THINK IN THIS
COMMITTEE. SEVEN ATTACK OR THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
IN OPPOSITION WE ALIGN OURSELVES
OF MR GOT RIGHTS COMMENTS IN IT
COME TO NOTICE AND URGE THE
AUTHOR AND COMMITTEE TO CONTINUE
WORKING ON THAT ISSUE WE ALSO
OPPOSE AND PRIVACY GROUNDS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OR HAVE CONCERNS OF
THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
CENTER WHICH LIKE CLOSE PLEASE.
WELL I I REALLY DO APPRECIATE
THAT THE ROBUST DISCUSSION AND
AND I MEAN ULTIMATELY I I REALLY
THINK WE WE LOOK AT THIS IS
GETTING TO THE CORE GOALS.
THAT CENTER SOME MILLION -- LAID
OUT WHEN HE WAS FIRST PROPOSING
THE BILL AND AND THIS WAS
ALLOWING.
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES TO DO
THE FINANCIAL ACCOUNTING
FUNCTIONS THAT THEY NEED TO DO
IN TERMS OF ENFORCEMENT -- BUT I
WHERE I STAND VERY COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION --
AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD
SPECIAL OVER TO IT AT THE
PRIVACY COMMITTEE TO ENSURE THE
THEY KEEP PRIVACY ISSUES ARE ARE
ADDRESSED AND AND THAT THIS
REALLY YEAH.
TREATS CONSUMERS AS THEY ARE TO
BE TREATED WITH FAIRNESS AND
WITH RESPECT FOR THEIR PRIVACY --
AND JUST THIS IS ULTIMATELY ALL
ABOUT.
ONLY ABOUT ALLOWING THE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES -- TO ME
TO PERFORM THEIR BASIC FUNCTIONS
THAT WE EXPECT THEM TO TO
PERFORM IN ORDER TO CARRY OUT.
THE THE WORK THAT WE'VE BEEN
TAUGHT WE WE WE TRUSTED THEM
WITH SO -- I WILL SAY MY STAFF
HAS CONNECTED WITH LITIGANTS TO
GET A BETTER SENSE OF THE HARM
THEY SUFFERED -- THEY SEEM TO
HAVE TROUBLE COMING UP WITH MUCH
THAT IS REALLY TANGIBLE -- YOU
KNOW NONE OF THE LET IT LIKE
IT'S A SHOWN THAT THEIR CLIENTS
PERSON ONE IN FIVE FIVE ONE
INFORMATION WAS SOLD TO
MARKETERS ARE USE ANYWAY THAT --
ANY ANYTHING EXCEPT FOR USED TO
FACILITATE THE COLLECTION OF
TOLLS WHICH AS I SAY WAS
EXPLICITLY MENTION AS IT AS A
IMPORTANT TASK AND FUNCTION OF
THE AGENCIES NEED TO CARRY OUT.
BY SUBMITTING HIMSELF WHEN HE
PROPOSED THE BILL -- SO.
YOU KNOW I I CERTAINLY DON'T.
LOVE TOLL ROADS WHEN I I'M I'M
I'M ON THE WEST COAST GUY THINK
THEY'RE THEY'RE WAY TOO
COMMITTED TO THE MONEY SITE IS
BECAUSE I COLLEGE ICE TO MY
WITNESSES HERE BUT YOU KNOW I
REALLY DO YOU SAY THAT.
YOU KNOW THE DAY OF THE AGENCIES
AND MANAGE THEM ARE DOING
EXACTLY WHAT CENTERS MILLIONS
OWN FACTUALLY CLAIM WAS
PERMITTED UNDER THE STATUTE HE
AUTHORED -- BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF LAWSUITS -- SEEMS TO REALLY
BE UNREASONABLY HIGH PRICE TO
ASK THE PUBLIC TO PAY IN AND
LET'S REMEMBER THAT'S MONEY IT'S
COMING OUT OF TRANSIT PROJECTS
HIGHWAY PROJECTS ETCETERA.
AND SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIGHT.
THANK SENATOR ALLEN -- AS MUCH
AS ANYONE I WANT TO PROTECT
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING FROM WAYS
FOR FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS.
I ENCOURAGE THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL IS UNDERS UNDER
FUNDED UNDER STAFF TO TO WORK
WITH THE TOTALING AUTHORITIES.
FOR TOLL EVASION THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AS MUCH AS THEY CAN
WE WORKED THROUGH LEGISLATION.
TO MAKE SURE THAT PROPER --
PLATES WERE ON THE VEHICLES SO
THAT FOR TELEVISION WE'VE WORKED
IN EVERY ASPECT IS THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
CAN PROSPER.
AND DO THE WORK THAT THEY THEY
INTEND TO DO -- BUT WHEN THIS
FIRST BILLS FIRST DISCUSSED WITH
ME.
I WAS TOLD IT WAS.
A DIFFERENT BILL AND WE WERE
CLARIFYING THAT WE WERE COVERING
LEGISLATION TEN WHEN WE PASS
THIS MEDIUM BUILD IN.
TWENTY TEN AND NOW THAT I OF NOW
I UNDERSTAND THE BILL GOES FAR
BEYOND WAS SOLD TO ME.
AND I WAS A LITTLE DISAPPOINTED
IN HOW THAT.
ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
AND FRANKLY FRUSTRATED WITH THE
WAY THIS WENT DOWN AND I EXPECT
BETTER FROM MY FRIENDS AND
TRANSPORTATION WORLD.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY WANT MY
SUPPORT.
AND I'VE GIVEN MY SUPPORT FOR
THIS INDUSTRY.
SENATOR ALLEN I APPRECIATE A
WILLINGNESS IN AGAIN.
I'VE NEVER SEEN YOU AGAINST THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS.
HERE WE ARE.
AND YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE YOU --
WHAT THE WILLINGNESS TO AMEND
THE BILL IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE --
IT'S PLEASE COOKIE PORTAL MY
CONSULTANTS SAY HAVE A REALLY
GOOD HANDLE ON THIS AND THEY
HAVE BEEN DOING THIS FOR MANY
YEARS AND WORK WELL.
WITH THE INDUSTRY -- I TRUST
THAT YOU WILL AND RESOLVE THIS
ISSUE BEFORE I SEE IT ON THE
FLOOR.
SO THAT I CAN VOTE YES ON WITH
THAT'LL BE LAID OFF THE BILL
TODAY.
AND AND HOPE IT BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THAT -- WHEN YOU GET
THAT ON THE FLOOR -- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL.
MR CHERRY I DIDN'T TO APPRECIATE.
TO COMMENTS BECAUSE THERE WASN'T
NO RECOMMENDATION I WASN'T SURE
WHERE YOU'RE GOING.
I THINK THE BILL IS A VERY
CREDIBLE FOUGHT FULL BILL.
AND THE SENATORS COMMITMENT TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES -- IN THE
PRIVACY COMMITTEE.
MEANS A LOT AND VERY HELPFUL.
THIS IS A THERE'S A PROBLEM
STATEWIDE WITH ALL THESE
AGENCIES RIGHT NOW AND WE NEED
TO DO OUR JOB AND HELP CLEARED
UP AND CLARIFY -- THE RULES IN
THE PROCEDURES.
AND SO I THINK IT'S A THOUGHTFUL.
WISE BILL AND AGAIN I APPRECIATE
THE COMMITMENT OF THE AUTHOR TO
ADDRESS THESE PRIVACY ISSUES --
IN THE APPROPRIATE COMMITTEE SO
ALL THE SUPPORTING THE BILL AND
IF WE DON'T ACT TODAY AND MOVE
FORWARD I THINK WE'RE JUST GONNA
YOU KNOW -- THIS CONTINUING
UNCERTAINTY WILL PREVAIL AND
THAT'S NOT AND THAT'S NOT GOOD.
FOR OUR MOTORISTS IN OUR STATE
SLOPPY SUPPORT IN THE BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT CLARIFICATION --
DO WE HAVE THE MOTIONS
[inaudible]
WHO?
THIS PHARMACY BIGELOW WERE THE
FIRST IN THE SECOND.
ADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL ROCK.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON PRIVACY.
FRAZIER.
FONG.
FONG I AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN
[inaudible]
BIGELOW.
HELLO I TI<c.cyan>.</c>
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE DALY.
DALY AYE DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA.
THE NINE IS ARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL LINE.
THE BILL IS TWELVE LEAVE ROLE
PERHAPS A MEMBERS [inaudible]
DR BEN.
SB
.
FIVE FORTY THREE HOW WE MADE YOU
DO HAVE A DO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WELL -- FOR SO I WON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT SB FIVE FORTY THREE
AND TWENTY FIFTEEN WE CAST FIVE
THIRTY TO ESTABLISH THE PEDAL.
POWERED QUADRA CYCLES I THINK
YOU'VE GOT THE BACKGROUND
BASICALLY CURRENT LOSS DUE TO
SUNSET JERRY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY AND SB FIVE FORTY
THESE SEEKS TO DELETE THE SUNSET
DATES OF THESE INNOVATIVE SMALL
BUSINESS CAN CONTINUE TO FLOOR
SHOPPING SAFELY ON CITY STREETS.
HAS SUPPORTED SEXUAL POLICE
DEPARTMENT NO NO VOTES REFORM
OPPOSITION AND I HAVE WITH ME --
MATTHEW C. CO OWNER OF SECTOR
BIKES BECAUSE FOR THE BILL AND
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CAN CHAIR COMMITTEE
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY SPEAK TODAY
AS BRUCE MENTIONED I'M MATH YOU
SEE I'M A CO OWNER HERE OF
SECTOR BIKE -- YOU'VE PROBABLY
SEEN OUR VEHICLES -- ROAMING THE
STREETS HERE IN DOWNTOWN
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SO -- HAVE
YOU HAPPY TO SPONSOR THIS BILL --
SB FIVE THIRTY ADDRESS KIND OF A
NEW EMERGING CONCEPT IN WORKING.
WORKING WITH SENATOR PAINS
OFFICE WAS -- HELP MANY YEARS
AGO WAS A VERY HELPFUL -- YOU
KNOW IT IS FURTHER LEGITIMIZE OR
IN THIS INDUSTRY BY SETTING.
THE VEHICLE SAFETY STAMP
STANDARDS OPERATIONAL
REQUIREMENTS AND FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS -- TO BUILD A
DETERRENT THIS IS RIGHT FOR
THEIR COMMUNITIES SO -- WE'VE
BEEN IN OPERATION FOR YOU KNOW
ALMOST FIVE YEARS NOW AND WE'VE
GROWN SIGNIFICANTLY
SIGNIFICANTLY WE'VE GONE FROM.
TWO TO TWO BIKES. TO FIVE SIX
EMPLOYEES [inaudible]
TWENTY FIVE OF WE HAVE WE'VE HAD
WE'VE HEARD MUCH OF THIS SAME
EXCITING DEVELOPMENTS BY OTHER
OPERATORS OUT STATE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE AUTHORS BILL MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MEDICINE BY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRAVEL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IN THE MAIL OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
THE LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC THROUGH LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OR SHARE CONCERNS
WITH THE AUTHORS BILL.
SING NINE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE CENTER WAS LIKE
CLOSE.
I SPECIAL YES ON EITHER THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR I'M GLAD
TO SEE THE CITIES WERE ABLE TO
RULE OUT THESE BICYCLES IN A
SAFE MANNER.
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT EFFORTS TO
BOOST LOCAL BUSINESS.
AND BRING EMPLOYMENT. TO OUR
DISTRICTS.
THAT'S OKAY PLEASE CALL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER HI.
FRAZIER AYE FONG AYE FONG AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I THAT IS FOURTEEN
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN -- FRESA
MEMBERS CONGRATULATIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU DOCTOR.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST THE LATE THE
GREAT [inaudible]
THE BILL [inaudible]
CENTER BUILT.
FIRST BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU
SECOND BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON
[inaudible]
MISTER BELL.
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING --
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION FIVE
THIS IS A RESOLUTION THAT URGES
CONGRESS -- AND THE PRESIDENT TO
WORK ON INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING.
AND LEGISLATION.
NOW -- CALIFORNIA'S
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE AS
WE ALL KNOW IS AGING.
AND WE PUT UP OUR MONEY RECENTLY
[inaudible]
BUT THERE HASN'T BEEN AN
INCREASE IN FUNDING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SINCE THE
EARLY NINETIES.
SO WE THINK THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SHOULD START TO
DISCUSS AND AND DEVELOP.
AT INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING AND
LEGISLATION -- WE NEED THE
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION TO BE
INCLUDED TO INCREASE MOBILITY.
REDUCE GRIDLOCK GRIDLOCK REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GASES WE NEED TO FIND
ARE CRUMBLING ROADS AND BRIDGES
ARE -- ARE -- TRANSPORTATION.
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED FOR FOR
GOODS AND FREIGHT MOVEMENT HAS
TO BE INCLUDED.
OUR PORTS.
ARE KEY ERROR ARE KEY DRIVERS
FOR OUR ECONOMY.
THESE PROJECTS ARE VITAL TO
PUBLIC SAFETY AND AND THE
ECONOMIC GROWTH THE CALIFORNIA.
SO.
I WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR WE HAVE
A RESOLUTION DOES NOT INCLUDE --
PROPOSING RAISING TAXES IT'S
SIMPLY OR JUST CONGRESS -- AND
THE PRESIDENT TO DEVELOP AND
PASS A COMPREHENSIVE
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE.
URGING CONGRESS AND THE
PRESIDENT TO FIND A WAY
RESTORING.
THE PURCHASING POWER THE FEDERAL
REVENUE SOURCES OR FIND A WAY TO
FULLY FUND THE HIGHWAY TRUST
FUND WHICH IS NOW.
BEING DEPLETED AND COULD GO INTO.
A ROOM.
ESSENTIALLY RECEIVERSHIP IF WE
DON'T -- DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE
SERGEANT I RUN RESOLUTION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR ANY MEMBERS
THE PUBLIC LIKE TEST FINES FOR
THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE.
THERE WAS THE PUBLIC LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION -- SURE
CONCERNS OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
SERVICE LIKE CLOSE.
ARJUNA VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF THE CENTER BILL THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION. FOR
TODAY WE FOUGHT TOGETHER YOU AND
I FOR TWO YEARS TO INCREASE OUR
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO
TRANSPORTATION WITH SB.
ONE AND IT'S STILL NOT ENOUGH.
IT'S TIME FOR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
STAND UP STEP UP AND DO ITS PART.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION TODAY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED FRAZIER
HI FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG NO AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO.
TO CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO DAILY.
DALY AYE DEEP.
DEEP NO FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON AYE GIPSON AYE
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA I IN THIS AREA IN.
THIS AREA AND I O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE.
THE BILL HAS ELEVEN WILL LEAVE
THEIR OPEN PERHAPS A MEMBERS
THANK YOU SENATOR.
THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING YOU DO
IN TRANSPORTATION [inaudible]
THIS.
SO WE'RE GONNA GO HEAD MOVE
FORWARD AND LIFT THE CALL SO FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS PLEASE HANG
AROUND GET YOUR NAME
[inaudible]
COUNTED [inaudible]
SECRETARY'S.
BEFORE.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR BERMAN.
BERMAN I CHU.
CHU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. GRAYSON.
GRAYSON HI [inaudible]
SHE DID.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I ITEM ONE SB SEVEN
BERMAN [inaudible]
BERMAN I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I NAZARIAN [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
NAZARIAN I THAT'S THIRTEEN
MEASURES OUT.
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB.
FORTY FOUR BERMAN HI.
BERMAN I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I NAZARIAN.
THIS AREA AND I THAT'S TWELVE
THE MEASURES OUT.
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
[inaudible]
FIFTY NINE BERMAN.
BERMAN I'M DALY.
DALY AYE GIPSON AYE GIPSON AYE
NAZARIAN.
THIS AREA AND I O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I THAT'S THIRTEEN THAT
MEASURE IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB [inaudible]
TWO TEN BERMAN.
BERMAN I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I NAZARIAN.
JERRY AND I THAT HAS TWELVE THAT
MEASURE IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER TEN SB FOUR HUNDRED
BERMAN.
BERMAN AM.
CHIU.
CHIU I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I DALY.
DALY AYE GIPSON HI GIPSON AYE IN
THIS AREA IN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I THAT HAS FOURTEEN
THAT MEASURE IS OUT ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN SB [inaudible]
FOUR OH TWO BERMAN [inaudible]
BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM.
AM I A DAILY [inaudible]
DALY I FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON HI GIPSON I IN
THIS AREA IN.
THIS AREA AND I O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL I THAT MEASURE HAS
FIFTEEN ICE [inaudible]
ITEM. TO GET THIS FRIEDMAN I TO
NOT VOTING THAT MEASURE HAS
FOURTEEN VOTES AND IT IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTEEN SB [inaudible]
FIVE FORTY THREE NAZARIAN
[inaudible]
BECAUSE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SB
FIVE FORTY THREE IN THIS AREA.
SYRIAN NOT VOTING THAT MEASURE
HAS FOURTEEN VOTES IT IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN SB SIX
TWENTY EIGHT BERMAN.
BERMAN I CHIU.
CHIU I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE DALY OUR DAILY
AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON I IN THIS AREA.
THIS AREA AND I O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL I THAT MEASURE HAS A
FIFTEEN I IS IT OUT.
ITEM NUMBER.
FIFTEEN SB [inaudible]
SIX SIX FOUR BERMAN [inaudible]
BERMAN I NAZARIAN.
HI.
NAZARIAN I THAT MEASURE HAS
SUPPORT TEAM I IS IT IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHTEEN S. J. R..
FIVE ITEM NUMBER -- FIFTEEN IS
THAT RIGHT.
YES HE VOTED [inaudible]
OKAY.
THIS IS THE LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
FOR THE ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE IS NOW COMPLETE THIS
HEARING IS ADJOURNED